Hey everybody that sound in the back is
not me going to the bathroom.
That's just pouring coffee.
Folks.
Don't get crazy.
This episode of the podcast is brought
to you by a new sponsor.
It's called blue apron and blue apron.
Uh,
I just,
I'm just try this out.
This week they sent it to me.
This is what blue apron is.
It's a way to get all the ingredients
for healthy meals along with recipes
shipped to your house.
It's pretty interesting.
Um,
I was a bit skeptical at first.
It was like,
what,
what exactly they're going to do and
then they send you this thing.
It's got this sheet,
it's got photographs of what everything
looks like,
shows you how to cook everything.
All the meals are between 500 and 700
calories per serving.
A really interesting way to low
calories,
low for how delicious they are.
It's all healthy,
excellent food and it's all stuff that
you don't have to go to a store,
you don't have to going where they'll
ship everything to you.
It's all like in these coolers that have
like,
I guess it's freeze dried or something
like not freeze dried.
What's that stuff called?
Dry Eyes.
Dry Eyes to keep it cold,
but it,
uh,
it sat inside my house for like 10 hours
and it was still nice and cold when I
opened it up and put it in the
frigerator.
Um,
they have all kinds of yummy stuff.
They have the step by step instructions
were said,
which picture with pictures,
totally idiot proof.
They work around your schedule and your
dietary preferences and the cooking
takes about a half an hour.
Shipping is completely free and you can
make meals like short rib burgers on
Pretzel Buns,
Kung Pao chicken tacos,
very delicious stuff.
You Cook incredible meals and you can be
blown away by the quality and the
freshness.
Blue Apron,
it's fast,
it's fresh and it's affordable to end
the stress of cooking.
Now go to blue apron.com/Rogan
and get your first two meals free.
That's right.
First two meals free.
Blue Apron.com/Rogan
is really interesting idea.
I've never heard anything like this
before and like I said,
I was kind of like a bit skeptical,
but the meals are delicious.
Last night I had had some,
I forgot the name of the Tacos,
but it was a steak Taco,
but they all the spices they give you
like onions,
garlic,
all these different things that chop up
was really kinda cool.
Uh,
so blue apron.com/Rogan.
And get your first two meals free.
I'm using it right now and as I use it I
will update you guys on all the new
ingredients and new,
different things that I try out.
So I'll keep you updated.
But so far so good.
I love it.
Blue Apron.com/Rogan.
Go there and get your first two meals
free.
We're also brought to you by ting and if
you go to Rogan.ting.com,
you can get in on what is going to be
the future of cell phone purchasing and
cell phone use in my opinion with Ting
does is they,
they rent the sprint backbone so it's
just like having sprint phone except you
have no contracts.
You have no early termination fees,
no add ons,
no bs,
no weird hidden payments that you have
to do to deal with.
Most of the time when you buy a cell
phone,
if you buy a cell phone and the cell
phone says it costs $200,
it's not really $200,
most likely it's probably quite a bit
more,
but what they do is they defer that
money over the course of the term of
your contract,
so the phone might really cost $600
bucks.
So for the next three years that you're
under contract,
you're slowly paying off that phone.
You don't realize that.
So when you go to try to cancel your
contract,
you owe them a bunch of money and it's
kind of annoying.
It's also annoying the way they have it
set up at most cell phone companies.
Accepting this is the only one I know of
that does it differently.
Ting has it setup where you only pay for
what you use.
Like say if you have like 120 minutes a
month plan,
most of the time you're not going to use
all that.
And what happens when you don't use it?
Nothing.
You don't get any money back.
If you use more,
you pay more,
they get you a fee.
But if you use less,
you do not get paid.
You don't get that money back with Ting,
you only pay for what you use.
It's an awesome company.
I really love doing business with them
because first of all,
they're completely,
totally ethical there.
They're also very generous.
When Tim had its two year anniversary
for no reason whatsoever,
other than the fact that they wanted to,
they decided to cut rates on slash rates
on their data,
which really affected heavy users.
Especially 98 percent of people would
save money with Tim and that is because
they do mobile differently.
Go to [inaudible] dot ting.com
for more details.
They have all the new and greatest
android phones available,
including the iphone five.
You can get the iphone five for 260
bucks.
That's ridiculous folks.
It's cheap.
It's easy.
It's awesome.
And they have been a sponsor of the
podcast for a long time.
So if you were in the market for a new
cell phone,
please give them a try.
They support us and we support them.
Rogan.ting.com.
Go there and save 25 bucks off of a new
cell phone then.
That's it for now.
But let's just get cracking.
We got a lot of interesting stuff to
talk about.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we have a very special guest.
Cue The music Camp Jamie and I'll
introduce him to the world,
the Joe Rogan experience
Joe Rogan podcast.
We have.
Is it okay to call you the Godfather?
Please do the godfather here.
Ladies and gentlemen,
and this is in reference to a music
video that you were a part of.
God.
How do I say your last name?
Sat.
Just sat.
That's fine.
Cad side.
It's two a's.
It gets tricky when this next phase
because it's a guttural sound from
Arabic.
Oh,
how will you say it?
Side side.
But since most westerners couldn't
pronounce that,
you just do the AA.
Oh,
that's got to be annoying.
That's where this.
We're like,
we gentrify everything.
We push everything down.
And uh,
you are,
you are an expert in evolutionary
psychology and in this is where rick,
it's really fascinating evolutionary
psychology and its effect on
consumerism,
right?
So I basically apply a evolutionary
psychology on this time that are
consumed with Tori nature.
What are the biological forces that can
pedal us to be the consumers that we are
defined consumption very broadly.
It's not just consuming Coca Cola,
but we consume friendships,
we consume religion,
we consume marriages.
So it's a consumption with a capital c.
that's fascinating to me because you
know,
we have these general definitions that
we use in,
in,
in culture.
And one of them is consumerism.
Consumerism almost always pertains to
buying things,
but what you're looking at it.
And as I like that better because it is
kind of what we do.
We do consume relationships.
Don't want exactly.
I mean we consume cultural products,
right?
So why is it that certain songs are so
appealing to us?
I mean,
what,
what are,
what is it about song lyrics that are,
that trigger an emotional pull us why
our movies appealing?
Well,
you study these sculptural products
because they say something really about
the evolution of the human mind that's
do you study songs that are annoying as
well because I've always wondered why
some songs are like super appealing to
some,
but then just infuriating to other
people.
So that would probably be a musicologist
who would study the,
the musical structure of songs to know
what makes them appealing or not.
I'm specifically looking at the lyrics.
So for example,
if you look at hip hop videos,
they're wonderful Darwinian laboratory
because all the political correctness is
cut out and basically your real
Darwinian being shines through,
right?
So men are going to signal,
Hey,
I've got the Missouri Audi,
I've got the Porsche,
get with me.
Uh,
women are going to signal,
you know,
beauty markers.
It's only women,
for example,
who denigrate men if they have low
social status,
right?
It's never going to be a guy saying,
Hey Linda,
you,
you don't work hard enough so you're not
ambitious enough.
I'm not going to have sex with you.
But the other way around you see a
million songs like that,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
All you know,
like she,
she's not a gold digger,
but yeah,
that's very interesting.
I'm a musicologist.
Is that a real person?
A real person?
Yes.
That's a musicologist would study lyrics
and dope and.
Well they would probably study that.
The structure structure of the musical
notes.
Right?
So what,
for example,
what is it?
That's what types of notes are innately
appealing to people.
Uh,
so that,
that's certainly not what I do.
I'm,
I'm looking only at song lyrics as one
of many types of cultural products.
The lyrics would be the thing that would
be annoying to most though.
I mean that would be the thing that
would really try them out as being
annoying.
Like some inane,
retarded songs.
They love Taylor swift.
What you said it,
not me.
How dare you,
how dare you suffered?
I know one thing,
if you date Terrell's swift,
you're a fucking idiot because that shit
will write songs about you for the end
of time.
She's got whole books about John Mayer.
Is that his name?
Aaron Meyer.
I always say it wrong.
John Mayer chicks copy books on that.
So that's unfair.
Imagine that.
Um,
so your,
your thing would be more along the lines
of studying,
like why people are,
why they find it appealing,
like the rap type song,
why they find it appealing like Taylor
swift,
the contents of those songs,
if you take a,
a ancient Greek poem,
right?
We still studied at university today,
3000 years later,
precisely because that poem is going to
speak to certain realities,
sibling rivalry,
status,
competition,
parental conflicts with,
with their offspring,
a paternal uncertainty.
All of these factors as what makes
literature interesting.
So we could study those ancient Greek
poems today and still address updates
with us precisely because they are
speaking about some universal truths.
That is amazing,
isn't it?
That stuff from 3,300
plus years ago is still studied on a
daily basis,
but some books from like 50 years ago
gone.
Yeah.
That's got to be frustrating as hell.
If you're a writer,
if you're an author and you're just
like,
what?
That guy is so overrated.
I'm so tired of Ealing hearing about,
you know,
aristotle,
go fuck yourself,
bro.
That shit was so long ago.
You didn't know anything or they knew a
lot.
They didn't know a lot of.
Certainly knew the mysteries of human
nature.
I'm fascinated by that.
I am absolutely fascinated by what was
going on thousands and thousands of
years ago and like what was the mindset
and communication with those people and
you can kind of pull a little bit of it
out of the writing,
but man,
if I could go back in time to some.
I mean it would have to be a culture
obviously that speaks English where it
could understand what they're saying,
but I think that would be incredibly
fascinating to go back three or 4,000
years ago and communicate with people.
Just try to figure out how they see the
world.
Absolutely.
You know,
a lot of people are very stuck on
identifying cultural differences.
Right?
So the French eat this type of food,
the Malaysians do this type of dance
and.
But what they miss is that underneath
all of these important cross cultural
differences is this bedrock of human
universals that make us a lot more
similar than different from one another.
And especially in the social sciences
where people are really focused on just
identifying differences,
differences,
but of course there are also things that
are so common so that,
for example,
beauty markets,
there are certain beauty markers that if
I went to the Yanomami tribe in the
Amazon,
they're going to find exactly the same
things,
attractive and the beautiful girls in
rap videos as you and I would.
And that's because those beauty markers
are evolutionary markers and so yes,
culture matters.
Nobody denies the fact that the culture
important,
but underneath these cultural
differences is a biological,
biological heritage that makes you and I
are very similar to one another.
What,
what changes over time that makes beauty
markers differently?
Like I've always been fascinated,
but like if you look at the renaissance
paintings,
the women were very.
You wouldn't,
you can't even call them voluptuous
there.
They're overweight.
Ruben Ruben asked like they eat a lot of
Ruben's.
What is she even asked me?
Well,
it's rubin was a painter who was
particularly had a pension for drawing
these voluptuous women who was a fatty
chaser.
It was a bit of a fatty chase.
Ruined that.
I must say this is the first time that
I've held an interview where fatty
chaser has come up,
so thank you.
Well,
you need to be involved in more
podcasting because fatty taste.
It's important to say now that you're
fat shaming,
that's the newest thing.
Do you follow these ultra super
sensitive terms and their evolution?
You said we've got up to three hours.
I could talk about this for about 30
hours.
Poly.
I actually went recently to a and we
come back.
We'll come back to the rubin,
so we'll come back to that.
I recently gave a talk at Wellesley
College,
all women's college women's college data
chicken went there.
Is that right?
Times are rough.
Tough time.
It.
Taylor swift.
No,
it was a gal who did not shave her legs
because it was patriarchal to beautify
yourself there.
Yeah,
she can pull it off.
She was blonde,
but whoa.
Her roommate was a Hobbit,
showed hairy feet old thing,
but hey,
you know,
whatever.
It's just cultural norms.
That's it.
So anyways,
I give a talk there under this thing
called the freedom project,
which tries to promote sort of iconic,
classic ideas that kind of break the
shackles of political correctness and
uh,
it was just amazing that kind of stuff
that was happening there.
I mean I'll just give you one or two
examples.
A,
apparently it was a form of oppression
to assume for a professor to assume that
when he meets students he right away
categorizes them as either being male or
female.
So for example,
if I see you in my class and I say,
Hey sir,
while the law,
well that would be a form of oppression
because I'm assuming based on your outer
markers that you are male rather than
what I should do is sort of do a quick
polling of each person in terms of how
they'd like to be addressed.
So you may be biologically male but you
are a gender,
whatever,
transgender,
you'd be queer,
it can be queer,
you can be this.
So as you know,
facebook has 50 markers,
the 50,
there's 55,
zero,
zero.
I could only,
I could 10,
right?
Wow.
Fifty 50.
And for folks who don't know,
queer is not a slur.
When I'm saying Queer,
I'm like,
Hey,
I'm not saying it like that.
Queer is,
they do not want to be interpreted as
male or female.
They want to be just whatever they are.
Right?
And so now you have at universities of
discussion as to whether you should have
not male and female bathrooms,
but you should have gender neutral
bathrooms.
Uh,
and so on and so forth.
And so on.
Academia and the world that I reside in,
it's,
it's there.
Why is it getting so squirrely?
What's going on?
Are we too soft?
Do we have to hunt for our own food?
Do we have to deal with the winter more?
Do we have to like chop wood to keep
warm?
What is making us concentrate on these
frivolous matters of like,
it's not just a politically correct
thing,
it's like it's coddling the most
ridiculously over-sensitive notions that
human beings have ever constructed.
I think we've been parameterized by an
astonishing farm of political
correctness.
I mean what [inaudible] like,
like a parasite that.
Oh,
right.
So in the same way that I like that
word,
that viruses can enter your body,
a virus,
he's of the mind can also take over
your,
your.
I mean religion is an example of a Mima
plex form of.
I mean some people would be upset by
what I'm saying,
but a form of parasite that kind of
rewires your thinking.
So political correctness is a,
an astonishing form of parasitic
thinking where everything is viewed
through the lens of I should not offend
anyone and so common sense and just
reason goes out the window and the
pursuit of non offense.
You know what though I have an issue
with it,
that most people who practice this in
the extreme form,
they say that they should not offend,
but you know who they offend,
they offend anyone who does not agree
with their notion that you should not
offend.
They will be violent and angry and
fucking incredibly insulting to people
who do not agree with their,
their,
their terms of what is a fence and
what's not offensive.
I have been some of the Ma,
meanest,
nastiest things had been said to me by
people who claim to be a in this sort of
ultra sensitive super open minded
category,
which is quite fascinating to me that
you're exactly right.
I'll give you a fantastic quote.
I might be paraphrasing.
It's like that.
I think it's Thomas Soul A.
I'm an economist who basically was
criticizing so-called diversity,
so.
Right,
so at American universities or in
western universities,
everybody talks about diversity,
but the only form of diversity that's
not allowed is intellectual and
political diversity.
Right?
So,
so you want.
We want diversity in terms of skin
color.
We wanted diversity in terms of sexual
orientation.
We want diversity in terms of genders.
Right?
So all forms of diversity are welcome,
but don't you dare step out of line with
the accepted politically correct
positions.
Now that's diversity that we don't want.
Yeah.
What is that?
What?
I mean,
how do they not see that thought?
Police?
Yeah,
and I face it.
I mean eventually I guess we'll come
back to my work.
I face it very much in my work because
I,
I rile up all sorts of different people
out of the woods,
the woodwork.
So for example,
radical feminists hate my work because
how dare you say that we are biological
beings?
How dare you say that there are sex
differences.
A postmodernist will hate my work
because the truth is all relative.
There's no such thing as scientific
truth.
It's all relative.
Uh,
the religious folks will hate my work
because if Darwinian theory is correct,
it is a then where is God in all this?
So there's this long queue of people who
will come out of the woodworks to
criticize you.
Not for any valid scientific reasons,
but because they,
it,
it shakes their ideological beliefs.
It's fascinating to me the parallels
between religious nutters and
politically correct nutters because it's
very similar in a lot of ways that their
ideology is just so cemented in their
consciousness.
More bile.
It's rock solid.
It's not going anywhere.
If you disagree,
you patriarchal piece of shit,
you know,
male fucking suppressor,
you horrible thing.
It's,
it's quite fascinating if,
if,
if there aren't,
not,
if they're not differences,
any differences in the sexist,
what do they use these radical
feminists,
what do they use to define the reason
why humans have such varying behavior
between the male and female gender?
Are you ready for this?
Everything.
Short of genitalia is a social
construction,
right?
So even for example,
the fact that Baba grew up to be a,
a block center for the University of
Oklahoma,
and hence he could bench press 500
pounds.
That's not due to,
for example,
any physiological reasons that he is so
strong.
It's because what happened is his
parents,
uh,
aggressively nurtured rough tumble play.
Whereas for girls,
they told them,
listen to them that you should not be
playing so rough and that then either
gives the green light or the red light
to express your physicality.
That's insane.
That's absolutely insane that that idea
is insane.
That there's not a difference in the
physiological properties of the bodies
of men and women.
I mean the biological differences are
scientific.
While they are there.
There are some feminists and I,
again,
I'm paraphrasing the quote,
they'll say there's no such thing as a
male or female brain as there is no such
thing as a male or female pancreas or
liver.
Right?
So,
so the Oregon that defines your
personhood is actually gender neutral.
Now,
that is astonishing because we are a
sexually reproducing species,
so one of the foundational tenants on
which biological understanding happens
is that we have two types of
polymorphisms.
If you'd like to type,
we have a male and a female so that we
could sexually reproduce.
So the idea that much of this as social
reconstruction,
this social construction is just
laughable.
I think it comes though,
I mean just to be fair to them,
I think it originally comes from a
desire to fight sex,
institutionalized sexism,
but what happens is that they mix
equality under the law as being
indistinguishable beings,
right?
We we could be different beings yet we
should be equal under the law,
but they argued that if you admit to the
fact that we are different than that
makes it easier for the status
quo,
sexist,
patriarchy to maintain it's privileged
position and so they create this edifice
of the past 50 to 100 years of social
science research that is completely
laughable,
but that they hang onto like religious
beliefs.
It's so fascinating.
There was a woman that has a video
online on youtube where she claimed that
there is no difference in the physical
strength of men and women and it's just
that men have been encouraged to engage
in weightlifting and all these different
things that women did the same thing.
They'd be just as strong.
That is insane.
It's so insane.
Have 10 times more testosterone than
women.
Is that a social construction?
Well,
it's also insane because women who are
athletes,
women who are elite world class
if they compare their hand strength to
men who don't even exercise,
men are stronger.
Just the ability to grab things and grip
things.
Right.
There was an issue where there was a
woman who is a transgender,
she became a transgender woman and she
used to be a man.
She was a man for 30 years and then she
didn't tell anybody,
start fighting women and women's mma and
I was furious.
I went crazy about it and I got so much
hate from people that were calling me
transphobic because you're transforming
and I'm like,
that's amazing.
Like you don't understand.
There's a difference in the male frame.
There's a difference in the shape of the
hips,
the dye,
the mechanics of the short,
like everything.
The whole body is built different and
not only that,
the fact that it takes 30 years,
like you're 30 years of being a man with
full testosterone and then it takes like
10 years before your bone density even
starts decreasing,
but they wanted to make it so it's
completely indistinguishable and they
also have support from transgender
surgeons,
which is quite fascinating and
completely biased.
These transgender surgeons who want to
or reassignment doctors and they want to
pretend that their exact equals
physiologically.
I got.
Sorry on that.
So in my first book I talk about John
Money,
who was a very famous psychologist at
Johns Hopkins,
really around maybe the fifties to
seventies.
He was a big gender theorists who
basically argued that everything is due
to socialization so that when surgeons
would go see him because they had to do
gender reassignment either,
for example,
let's say at a circumcision,
you in the rare case where you botch the
circumcision and now you have a problem
in terms of having a functioning penis
or if you have,
for example,
a condition,
a micro penis where you're unlikely to
be a functioning mail when you grow up,
while he would say don't worry about it,
just have the surgery,
put a dress on the kid and raised him as
a girl and they'd be absolutely no
problem.
And of course the reality is that that's
not how biological sex is determined.
And the most famous cases,
David Reimer,
who was one of his patients who after
having gone through the treatment,
committed suicide.
Yeah,
I remember that case.
So it was a fascinating story.
The,
um,
the reality of,
of what you said,
one of the more fascinating aspects of
it is the difference between us all
being equal as human beings and being
the same because we are not,
we're not equal,
we are very different,
but we all should be equal as far as our
rights.
Right.
You know,
as far as how we're treated by each
other and the law and what a person can
get away with.
You know,
what,
what keeps our society civil and kind.
Yeah.
Those,
that we should all have equality
including children and old people and
everyone.
Everyone should have equality in that,
in that aspect.
That's what,
what makes a civilized caring society,
but the idea that there's no differences
as far as the other thing that we are
equal as far as like physical strength
or as equal as far as like our wants and
desires and needs.
That's,
that's denying hundreds of years of
literature of the struggle,
the struggle in all cultures between the
male trying to understand the female,
the female trying to understand the male
were completely alien to each other.
We exist amongst each other when we
gather information over a long period of
time,
but then we say ridiculous things like
here's one of the things that people
love to say,
happy wife,
happy life,
right?
Why is that?
Because make her happy and she'll stop
screaming at you.
Don't understand her.
Just make her happy,
do whatever she wants,
and then she'll calm down and you'll be
good.
But believe me,
you can't just be yourself.
You can't just be what you want to be
and do what you want to do because
that's going to drive her fucking crazy
because you want to have sex with 100
women who want to drive 50,000
miles an hour.
You want to disappear for weeks at a
time.
I
thought by the Patriarchy you had been
given the.
I've been brainwashed,
brainwashed by the,
by the way,
speaking of sexual variety,
which is kind of a central issue in
evolutionary psychology.
Uh,
you should see some of the hate mail I
get when I state something has been out.
As you know,
men would have evolved a greater pension
for sexual variety for terribly trivial
reasons.
To explain,
right?
I mean women have a think called greater
parental investment,
right?
Women on average have from from there,
when the he start to,
when they have menopause,
400 x 400 x,
so it's a scarce resource.
Men and one ejaculation have 250
spermatozoa,
so our gametes are very cheap and
abundant,
and then of course you add the cost of
gestation,
right?
But the likelihood of having mortality
when you were giving birth.
So for all these reasons,
women have much greater minimal parental
obligations.
Therefore evolutionary theory would
predict that they would be much more
judicious when they're making a choice
because if they make a poor mate choice,
that looms much larger for them.
That on the other hand,
for men,
the costs of making a poor mate choice
are not as great,
but the benefits of having multiple
meeting opportunities are quite
beneficial and therefore that's why on
average you expect men to have a much
greater pension for sexual variety.
Now that's been documented in 17
trillion different ways and yet you
still have people that will send you
hate mail saying,
Mike,
God,
are you a pig?
How could you promulgate
this garbage will you?
I think when you're looking at human
beings and you're talking about these,
these variables,
you're looking at it as objectively and
scientifically as possible.
When people want that concrete world
that we've discussed this political
correct concrete world politically
correct,
they have this resistance to looking at
it in any way other than the way that
they have.
It's completely non scientific and
that's why it's religious,
right?
Absolutely,
and that's actually one of the
criticisms that you often get about
evolutionary psychology.
People think that you are trying to
justify behaviors.
For example,
if you explain why people are likely to
cheat and they're on their monogamous
unions,
then they say,
oh,
well you're.
You're offering father to why people
should do it out.
Of course,
my rebuttal is I'm.
I'm certainly doing no such thing.
Similar to how an oncologist studies
cancer.
He's not justifying counselor.
He's not for cancer.
He's right.
He,
he just explains he or she explains
cancer and so I don't have a moral
position,
right?
I don't come to the table when I'm doing
my scientific research hoping for one
thing or another.
The data speaks for itself,
but again,
the ideologues will say no,
but if this forbidden knowledge gets
out,
it makes it easier for people to justify
this behavior or that behavior.
It's absolutely fascinating to me how
human beings react and act and so this
subject is quite near and dear to my
heart.
I love it.
I just,
I'm.
I'm fascinated by the cast of it all.
I love watching people flail and scream
and get angry about whether it's
religious anger,
like people who are like legitimately
Christian,
like I love the God hates fags people,
the Westboro baptist.
I don't love them.
I love everybody.
In one way I would like everybody to be
nice,
but I love the fact that they exist
because I'm absolutely fascinated by
their folly.
I'm absolutely fascinated by this idea
that they have in their head that's so
concrete that they believe that soldiers
are dying because men are being allowed
to marry other men.
It's unbelievably weird,
but compelling to me and in,
in,
in an equal way.
The idea that you saying that there is
some sort of an invested commitment that
a woman has an a man does not have
objectively just looking at us as a
biological reproducing species that you
had experienced hate because of that.
As a scientist,
as a person,
just analyzing data.
I'm amazed and I'm fascinated.
I'm just drawn into it.
I can't help myself.
You want to talk about some religious
stuff?
Sure.
Uh,
well,
uh,
you know,
I was born in Lebanon,
uh,
were Lebanese Jews.
Uh,
although I'm,
I'm a non believing Jewish guy.
How dare you.
I know,
I know you believe in some things.
Tell you what I believe it's science and
truth and uh,
and so we escaped Lebanon actually
during the civil war.
My parents in 80 were kidnapped
by father,
the very peaceful because,
you know,
it's all peaceful.
Uh,
and uh,
and then after that we,
we've never gone back to Lebanon and so
I,
from a very young age,
I think I already had sort of the innate
pension to question religious belief,
which certainly created fiction within
my family because you should just
believe in shut up,
right.
But then when I saw the,
the,
the hatred that religion in genders
firsthand,
right?
I mean facing execution as we were
trying to escape Lebanon and then coming
to the west,
I think I became that much more forceful
in my convictions to,
to,
to try to combat religious dogma and of
course some of the biggest hate mail
that you get this when you do that.
And I've even had real professional
situations where I've,
I've lost professionally because of my
position is actually here in California.
I've had several schools who otherwise
were very,
very interested in making me very,
very lucrative offers who after maybe
doing a bit of due diligence on me and
seeing that I'd written stuff that was
critical of religion.
Suddenly I became persona non grata.
Really?
That's fascinating.
I wouldn't think that there'll will be
the case as far as they are.
They're even schools in southern
California that won't,
and they do this legally because they
are religiously founded institution.
If you're not the seventh,
seventh day adventists,
we can grant you tenure it.
There's another school that had a god
squad whereby you go up in front of the
Gospel.
I mean,
that's literally their term where,
uh,
you have to sort of show that you're
accepting Jesus in your heart.
And I remember when I school,
that's a school college,
very,
very prominent school.
Please.
Then it though.
Can you write it rhymes with Layola
Marymount?
No,
it's not,
but it's within that general area.
Uh,
there's another school three years ago
who was going to make me a huge,
huge offer in Orange County that didn't
work out now to the person who wanted me
to appear in front of the God squad.
This was several years ago when I was at
UC Irvine.
I told him,
you do realize that I am a atheist.
Lebanese Jew.
Evolution is so it's going to be.
It's going to be a while before I accept
Jesus in my heart and it his answer was,
well,
no,
but don't worry.
We'll,
we'll coach you as to,
as to what to say.
Oh,
so that's a euphemism for lying,
right?
How's that fit with the whole real?
So you know,
this is right here in 21st century,
southern California in academia,
you know,
you better hold certain religious
beliefs,
otherwise we'll punish you.
Jew.
Boy,
that's amazing.
And that's some colleges and then or
some universities and the universities
to complete opposite.
If you're not an atheist,
I'm sure that you'd take a lot of slash
true at other universities or in
academia in general,
it is quite a progressive to criticize
certainly Christianity,
right?
Because you're seen as a progressive guy
who doesn't buy into all this brunch
aid,
superstitions,
but there is one religion that
Islam,
she Islamophobia.
Isn't that fascinating?
I love that.
This is same ultra progressives that
would give you a million different ways
to address someone based on whatever
gender they identify with or you know,
whatever the fuck else.
Weird ultra super sensitive thing.
I find that completely fascinating.
This Islamophobia thing you find,
there's several websites that I frequent
just to freak myself out,
and uh,
the,
the super sensitive ones on a regular
basis,
we'll go over this Islamophobia.
Well,
because
it's,
uh,
it's actually a very astute way to,
to have intellectual warfare.
You're actually saying that people who
are concerned about particular aspects
of this ideology are crazy,
right?
They suffer from a phobia,
so you are denigrating them at their
core.
You must be nuts to actually fear this.
And actually the term started as you may
or may not know,
it started with the Muslim Brotherhood,
a very smart strategy where they knew
that the west is very open to being
tolerant and so on.
And so they kind of piggybacked on that.
And so in academia you just never
criticized that one I got.
Now that's very dangerous because in a,
in a sane world,
all beliefs should be open to criticism.
Absolutely.
And not only that,
how about the one that is responsible
for most of the suicide bombing?
Some of phobic.
I am Islamophobia.
Set it.
I'm Islamophobia,
Juha phobic.
I'm Catholic,
a phobic Christian of phobic.
I'm afraid of all of your reason.
Fillic you love the reason that I do.
Well,
I,
I was raised a Catholic for a very short
amount of time and uh,
I got very lucky.
I had a very tumultuous childhood and
when I was in first grade my parents put
me in Catholic school and up until then
I was obviously don't remember much of
this because it was,
but I was very religious and it was
because my parents were divorcing and
there was a lot of violence in the
household and I have this idea in my
head that somehow or another God was the
right way and everybody else was wrong.
Going to Catholic school cured me of
that entirely.
The nun that I had,
sister Mary Josephine,
I don't remember much about being six
years old,
but I remember that bitch.
She,
she was very important to me.
she really straightened me out because I
realized that she has no connection
whatsoever to anything holy or majestic.
She represented and she,
she showed all of the horrors of
humanity.
Meanness,
evilness,
being nasty to children,
fearmongering and this,
this is ailia killed everything.
All the above.
It was just,
it was nothing,
nothing holy about it.
It was pretty obvious pretty quickly
that it was all bullshit.
So I was cured from one year of Catholic
school.
I told my parents was gonna run away
from home if they tried to put me in
second grade.
Wow.
Yeah.
I was like,
I'm done.
Like you don't understand what it's
like.
I went from,
you know,
being around my mother was this great
person,
sweet my grandparents,
or great to all of a sudden,
you know,
I didn't go to kindergarten.
I just went to first grade.
It was my first year in school to being
round these monsters and this monster
school that was just filled with
darkness.
It was like the whole school was just
dark.
All the priests,
the,
I remember their faces,
they all had these gin blossoms all over
their faces from drinking,
you know,
and the nuns were all overweight and
bitter and angry and they're fucking
skin was having a bad relationship with
their face.
It was like hanging off of them.
Everything about them was just
monstrous.
That evilness.
I'm keeping accounts that have the
amount of hate mail that's to
comfortable with come bitches.
Let it come.
I'll just send it right back to you.
I don't get it.
You know I.
I'm fascinated by it,
but I understand that people need that.
They have this desire to believe in
things.
I understand that,
but I don't understand how you can be a
rational,
intelligent,
objective person who looks at some shit
that people wrote thousands of years ago
and say,
no,
this is.
This is immobile.
This is exactly it's.
You cannot alter it.
This is what it is and this is.
This is written in stone.
This is.
There's no way around this.
This is God's word.
Anybody questions that as a full.
I do,
and in my one of my latest books,
I have a chapter which I think got me in
trouble with one of the southern
California schools that I was getting
enough from it because I've given them a
signed copy of that book and then they
probably got to that chapter.
It's called that chapter's called
marketing hope by selling lies.
And so what I do in that chapter,
as I go through different hope Adler's
of which religion is the greatest,
but others will be medical quackery,
self help,
gurus and so on.
So,
so different agents that peddle hope,
and I argue again from an evolutionary
perspective because they,
they're very successful because they
cater to these very basil,
Darwinian insecurities.
None greater than the very obvious one
of existential angst,
right?
We're the only animal that we're aware
of that actually is aware that we are on
a death sentence,
right?
I mean,
I know that I've got another thing,
luckily maybe 40 years,
right?
Well,
if I have high cholesterol,
I go to my physician,
he gives me lipitor,
boom,
ldl goes down,
everybody's happy,
but how?
What pill do I take to solve this really
looming problem that's at the end of the
road called my death?
Well,
different religions will give you
different dances,
but they all certainly promise you some
form of eternity.
It could be in the form of
reincarnation,
it could be,
I'll be with Jesus.
It could be a divergence,
but there are all sorts of ways by which
I could secure my attorney and I think
for most people it's very difficult to
not drink that kool aid.
I think it takes almost a pathological
and dysfunctional to
say,
I'm not going to buy that.
I realize that I've got 80 years and I'm
going to really do the best that I can
drink those 80 years.
I think it's a lot more comforting to
say,
no,
this part is going to go on forever.
It certainly more comforting.
It's also there's something about human
beings where we realized somewhere along
the line that it's.
There's no one alive that has any more
answers about what lies beyond the great
beyond after death.
What lies beyond the yawning grave.
No one has any answers.
You can't give you what the answer is.
Nothing.
Nothing you would hope so are you would
think that you have that answer,
but have you ever done psychedelic
drugs?
Haven't.
There you go so you don't answer so
quickly.
When I tell you there are two ways of of
seeking to reach and mortality at one of
course is it might seem a bit crass,
but through just the genetic
propagation,
your,
your children are in a sense your form
of that.
I don't buy that.
You don't like that one?
It's not immortal because the earth
doesn't last.
I mean,
unless someone figures out how to get
off the planet,
we only have what one point 9 billion
years.
I'm like,
yeah,
I mean we don't have enough time for
anything.
There's no way.
There's no in mortality unless there's
some sort of a fractal nature to the
universe where it's life and death is
just completely ongoing cycle where the
deeper you go it starts again and yeah.
I don't know about that.
I don't know about that either,
but it is possible.
The universe itself is so bizarre and
unexpected and the more you look into
the universe,
like I remember when I was a kid,
I used to think space.
I used to think of space like a
neighborhood.
I really did.
I,
I remember very succinctly that,
uh,
I would like look at like buck rogers
and all these different space,
like,
oh,
they're going to go over to this town
and they're going to come back and this
is our neighborhood.
They're going to go to that neighborhood
and come back.
And then as I got older and I started
studying astronomy and I started
studying the.
And as I got older also the knowledge
that they had about the amount of stars
changed and they started talking about
how there's more stars in our galaxy
than there are grains of sand on all the
beaches and all,
you know,
all the beaches on earth.
And then I remember just thinking like,
well,
this is a motherfucker of a
neighborhood.
Like this is starting to get really
strange.
All right?
And then as you get older,
still you realize that they,
there's no way they know how big it all
is.
They have a general sense of 14 plus
billion light years.
But then there's the fractal nature of
black holes.
The possibility that inside every galaxy
is a black hole that contains an
entirely new universe.
And this is something that's being
thrown about by,
not by freaks,
but by like real serious,
legitimate scientists.
So that alone is so bizarre.
The idea that you live and die seems
very trivial.
They come back again or reincarnation
mean why not?
If a,
if a supernova can exist,
no,
why is it so crazy that a person lives
for and just
continues to reincarnate?
Well,
and in light of all that vast vastness
that you said,
isn't it incredible that all of the
monotheistic,
Abrahamic religions would argue that on
some small speck of sand in some bronze
age point,
God spoke to some profit and told them,
you really better not eat pig know.
So in this great unit universe,
ca know this cosmos,
it's really important that you don't
wear leather,
leather shoes that young people or
whatever.
It's just astonishing to me that people
actually buy this stuff.
Well,
I think that the reason for the pig
stuff,
and there's,
there's,
I've,
I've talked about this recently with my
friend already who,
uh,
was raised very religious Judaism and
then as he got older just decided to
abandon it all.
Now he's at dirty comedian,
hilarious,
but um,
we were talking about that the pork
thing was probably due to diseases.
I talk about that in my analysis,
so I,
I don't,
I don't do the analysis for a pork,
I do it for shellfish and so if you look
at shelf red tide and things along those
lines so you can't tell which one is
infected,
you can't look at the water and,
and,
and predict which one would likely have
the bacteria.
And so all you know is that once in a
while somebody would eat it and drop
that.
Since you don't have any ability during
the bronze age to refrigerate and so on,
well you don't have any access to the
germ theory.
Certainly they didn't know anything
about that.
Well then it must be some mild
addiction.
And so you're exactly right that there
are very,
very clear,
obvious biological explanations for most
of these food taboos.
Yeah.
It's just ridiculous that in 2014 Peter
People don't realize the origins of
these.
Like yes,
it was a great idea 2000 years ago
before we understood thermometers that
you you have to cook your meat to 150
degrees that kills the bacteria and then
it's perfectly,
totally healthy,
but if you try to eat pork the same way,
you will try to eat venison,
you're going to get really sick and
that's why religions like,
hey look,
if we want to keep our people alive,
we've got to tell them not to eat.
This particular animal is an animal that
eats a lot of stupid shit.
Exactly.
Yeah,
so religion has been the biggest blow
back of your work or actually probably
the ones that are,
that were the most acerbic and their
criticisms have been other social
scientists even more.
Yeah,
because the social sciences have very
much developed over the past hundred
years with a complete rejection of
biology.
How is that a science then?
They called social sciences.
You rejected biology,
which is measurable and Social Sciences
sort of.
Well,
what they argue is that what makes us
human is that we transcend our biology,
so don't use the evolutionary mechanisms
that explain the behavior of the Zebra
and the dog and the mosquito to explain
our behaviors.
What makes us it human is
precisely that we're able to transcend
these biological imperatives.
And so,
uh,
the field of anthropology,
not anthropology,
which is a subset of anthropology that
recognizes biology,
but for example,
cultural anthropology is all about going
to all of these exotic cultures and
demonstrating how each culture is unique
and different.
And hence there are no such thing as
human universals.
A social psychology is pretty much
operated without any understanding of
biology.
So what I did in my work as I came along
and I founded this field which I coined
evolutionary consumption,
where I apply evolutionary theory in
biology to study consumer behavior,
but more generally my,
my real goal is to what I call maybe
it's a grand goal to Darwin eyes,
the business school.
The idea is that you can study anything.
You can't study invest investment
psychology or personnel psychology or
organizational behavior or consumer
behavior without recognizing that all of
these players are biological beings,
right?
The decision that you make if your blood
sugar is low and you're hungry is very
different than decision you make if
you're satiated,
right?
I mean,
that's a trivial example,
but a very obvious one.
So the idea that economists have spent
100 years developing all these fanciful
mathematical models without ever
recognizing that there are these
biological forces that compel us to be
the decision makers that we are is
astounding to me.
So the greatest blow back has been from
social scientists who typically have
been very reticent to accept what this
biology boys saying about consumer
behavior and so on.
Fascinating.
Not the good news.
Can I kind of go on please?
I always use a quote by a guy called the
JBS Haldane,
who was a very evolutionary geneticist
who was very quotable,
very had all these great clips.
So he said that there are four stages
that scientists go through before they
accept the theory.
And I'll start paraphrasing.
So Stage one,
this is bullshit.
This is garbage stage two,
well this might be true,
but it's rather perverse stage three.
Well,
this,
this is true,
but largely unimportant and stage four
or I always set so
the reason why that quote
captures,
I mean if I ever did an autobiography of
my scientific career,
I.
That quote is basically my book because
I've seen people go through these four
stages in their responses to my work.
At first I couldn't get an invitation to
go to to get 20 minutes at a,
at a conference to speak because what?
What does biology you have to do with
anything and now of course sciences and
author corrective process.
The evidence is coming in my way and I
don't mean to gloat about it.
Yeah.
Now they're all coming fast and furious.
You're the man and I remember 10 years
ago I've still kept your email where you
said I was a bullshitter.
No,
that wasn't me.
That must have been my research
assistant who hacked my email.
How Dane is a great guy to quote.
He had a fantastic quote that I love.
Not only is the universe queer than we
suppose it's queer than we can it that
you
know what,
you're my.
You're my new coolest guy to to actually
know who,
how Dane is your event.
Well,
it's a special quote.
That's just an amazing.
I'm the Beatles.
I don't know the exact.
Do you know this one?
No,
I think there are something like,
I hope I'm not getting it wrong,
but maybe 300,000
species of beetles and so in his quote,
he basically says,
you know,
if God exists,
he must have a particular penchant for
beetles for having spent so much effort
and coming up with all of these
different species variations.
Yeah,
no kidding.
Right.
What,
what is it frustrating being a man who
is an intellectual who is trying to go
over the variables and try to figure it
all out and piece it together.
Is it frustrating to you to see these
obvious biases and this is obvious,
muddy thinking that enters into this,
this sort of debate.
It is on two levels,
on sort of the intrinsic level.
I'm a dog,
a pursuer of the truth,
and so I almost get offended by these
positions and so in that sense it's
frustrating,
but there's also an extra,
like a real sort of tangible way that
it's frustrating.
A lot of these gatekeepers are the ones
who decide whether I get a position in
southern California not.
And so if I play within the paradigm,
if I do the research that is expected of
me,
that doesn't sort of bust any existing
theories that I'm good,
but if I'm this guy from the outside
who's trying to biologies the field,
well,
who,
who does this guy think he is?
So in that sense,
I think it's also frustrating and I,
my wife always tells me,
well,
don't worry.
I mean if you can keep this,
sorry,
it's,
it makes a big difference how you can
move it around.
Sorry,
I don't mean to interrupt.
So your wife tells you something.
My wife tells me,
you know,
I mean,
don't worry,
you know,
you'll get all your vindication.
I said,
well,
I don't want to get vindicated when I'm
dead.
The postmortems I want.
I want the rewards now.
And not,
not in a narcissistic way,
but because there are also perks to
people finding out that hopefully you
are correct.
Now the reality is that more and more
people are coming around and so if I
look at the level of hostility that I
faced 10 years ago versus today,
it's night and day.
What was the first major backlash that
you experienced?
What social scientists not being A.
I mean having my papers desk rejected by
editors.
So that's great.
Are you familiar with that?
To explain it for people.
So that means basically when you send
your paper to a scientific journal,
usually the editor will look at your
paper and say,
okay,
well here are three reviewers that I
think would be appropriate for this
paper.
And then he sends it off and then the
process starts and it goes back and
forth for probably several,
several years when he desk rejects says
he's basically saying that this paper is
not worthy of even going out for review.
And so,
you know,
I would send all of these papers to
these top journals and the editor would
write back to me.
Sorry,
I'm not even sending it through the
review process,
what do you remember what one of the
original ones was?
Was the subject of A.
Well,
the probably the first one was one where
I was introducing the theoretical
framework of how to apply evolutionary
psychology and understanding marketing
and usually the the,
the argument that I would receive it,
which which is breathtakingly inane and
it's stupidity as well.
Evolutionary theory is just a bunch of
just so storytelling,
right?
You just come up with these fanciful
post hoc stories since obviously you're
not conducting an experiment in a lab to
demonstrate the evolution and of course
that that is so laughable because if
that were true,
how is it that astrophysicists study the
origins of the universe that's 14
billion years ago,
right?
They certainly don't conduct an
experiment in the lab and to build their
own stars all stars.
Right,
so but,
but again,
if you're very parodic magically bound
to manipulating something in the lab,
then somehow evolutionary theory seems
epistemologically in terms of the
philosophy of science.
It seems as though it's.
You're just waving your hand and telling
stories.
Post hoc stories.
Now the reality is that that's exactly
the opposite of what we do.
If anything,
there is no intellectual idea that has
received as much empirical support as
evolution.
I mean it is as clear as gravity.
Yet people somehow can't get around to
understanding how you could explain
something that happened hundreds of
thousands if not millions of years ago.
And so the original rejections were
always,
oh,
but come on,
we don't take thing on faith here.
We need,
we need concrete evidence.
So that's how it all started.
So that was the first blow back.
Did you.
When did you hesitate when you first
experienced this?
Did you go,
man,
I'm going down a dark road and.
No,
because I.
and that's a great question because I
think I was fortunate enough to have the
personality for this endeavor.
In other words,
it's not just that you had to have the
brains to do what I was doing.
If I would suck my thumb going into a
fetal position and start crying every
time somebody rejected me,
rejected my work,
then I wouldn't.
But because I was a fighter,
because I was a high testosterone guy,
then that only compelled me to come back
and say I'm going to prove these guys
wrong,
but at the delayed the process,
because I was kept out of many of the
leading consumer behavior and marketing
journals for.
So I kind of went around them.
I published books that became best
sellers.
I published in medicine and Economics
and psychology and only recently have I
tried to come back to the to the folks
that I'm most trying to convince and
those are the consumer psychologist now.
Luckily I'm their friend,
but for years I was really sort of at
the periphery.
It's fascinating as well that the.
The attitudes about the subjects have
evolved and changed within science and
within modern academia.
It's,
it's,
it's
really interesting to see this sort of
evolution of these ideas and the
acceptance of ideas that didn't exist
before.
But along with the new craziness,
the new fat acceptance and you know,
all this other nonsense,
this new politically correct terms in
this parasitic thinking that you saw
described so well,
this is the new threat to,
to unbiased,
objective thinking.
Absolutely is desired and offend no one
ever.
Absolutely.
And,
and you know,
the reality is that now there's a thing
called,
have you heard of trigger warnings?
Love it.
I love them my whole life to trigger
warning.
That's exactly what I said.
I'm going to put in my course outline.
Warning life is a trigger warning.
That's it.
So,
I mean,
imagine that it.
As a matter of fact,
I,
in my Wellesley talk that I mentioned
earlier,
I put up a list of,
suggests the suggested topics that these
trigger warning folks were saying
required trigger warnings.
I mean,
it was literally everything.
That discussion of pregnancy,
of sex,
of disease,
of war,
of criminality,
of mating,
all of these things could potentially,
uh,
cause some distress to somebody and
should therefore come with a trigger
warning.
Now for somebody who escaped Lebanon
under immediate threat of execution,
I look at that and say,
we're,
uh,
this is a decadent society in that if
that's the things that worry people,
they should really go spend a day in the
neighborhoods where I grew up and then
maybe they'd have a different
perspective as to what they should be
picketing against.
I agree entirely in my term is,
I mean my,
not my term,
my thought is that people are just so
used to this soft life of everything
being really easy to achieve,
that they have never developed this
understanding of the,
first of all,
how fortunate we are to be living this
in this time and age to experience this
easy life that we live in,
but that we're really lucky.
We're really lucky and to focus on a
bunch of nonsense and to get carried
away thinking about all these ultra
supersensitive notions and to dwell on
them as if in some way you're going to
make the world a better place by doing
now.
Like it's nonsense.
It's preposterous because it's their
posers.
Right?
And so a way to demonstrate that.
I care,
but in doing it with very little cost,
to me,
it takes a lot more guts to stand up
against Islam than to stand up against
some hick evolution,
denying senator who's Republican.
So for example,
if I look at my facebook friends,
if I put up a post that is critical of
the senator who was a Redneck,
a Republican,
I'll get from my academic colleagues 80
likes and at some inane,
silly thing,
but if I put some horrifying reality
about 200,000
Syrians being butchered,
they are so loud in their silence
because that's scary.
Right?
And so the,
for example,
the western feminists are very,
very quick to chastise David Letterman
if he makes a sexist joke or whatever it
was to his intern that shows great
courage,
but so to speak against genital
mutilation in the Islamic world or other
parts of the world or all kinds of other
injustices that women face.
Well,
we should be quiet about that.
I mean,
look at the Ion Hirsi Ali issue.
I don't know.
Are you familiar with that?
No.
Do you know who I am?
Hirsi Ali is in Hirsi.
Ali is a woman who was born into Islam
who escaped an arranged marriage,
move to,
to Netherlands,
became a Dutch parliamentarian,
and then was part of a documentary that
was offensive to,
to,
uh,
some Muslims and then she had to have
then protection for the rest of her
life,
now has moved to the United States and
has spent pretty much her entire career
fighting for the rights of women,
not just Muslim women,
women in general,
but of course many Muslim women in those
areas are,
are mistreated.
So Brandeis University,
the sites to bestow her,
this is very recently,
a couple of months ago,
but still bestow her a,
I think,
uh,
maybe honorary doctorate or speech
convocation to speak at the convocation.
And then all of the professors rallied
against this woman who is speaking on
behalf of half the population called
women.
Right?
And they said this is a hate monger and
Islamophobic,
blah,
blah.
And so they rescinded her invitation.
Oh,
and there you go.
So,
you know,
I mean,
we're pretty much lost as a society if
we can't identify who the heroes are and
who is on the right side of each issue,
right?
Not just that,
but the educators are the ones that are
having this issue.
The educators are the ones that are
having a hard time recognizing who's on
the right side of things that I think
there's one very important thing that
you,
uh,
you brought up and it's the social
aspect,
the social gratification,
that's social reward aspect of
supporting things that we all agree upon
that these Hicks senators are bad,
that you know,
and then the scariness of Islam,
the,
the scariness of criticizing the Muslim
world.
And then this,
this concept of Islamophobia that's sort
of gotten to people's minds,
but that thing that people do where they
seek out what I call socially
Progressive Brownie points.
Exactly like men who declare themselves
openly feminists,
male feminists like,
look,
I'm a humanist.
I believe that we are all just brothers
and sisters on this planet.
All of us,
including people and other cultures and
countries.
And I'm not a nationalist.
I think it's all nonsense.
I really do.
I mean I would love it if we could all
understand each other.
I think it would make a lot more sense
if we spoke one language so I could
understand people in China,
but I don't feel about them any
differently than I feel about a guy
lives down the street.
I try very hard to work on that.
So when I get this,
this thing where people start
identifying with one gender and one
gender specifically and there's another
thing that men are doing where they're
not only proclaiming themselves as a
male feminist,
but they're also saying that if they are
unjustly accused of something that they
would happily be unjustly accused of
something if it could somehow another
prevent women from being persecuted.
What martyrs in that amazing.
They're so cool and strong like that,
but I think it's.
I don't know if you know the term
identity politics is that I've heard the
term,
so basically you have sort of this
balkanization of different identity
groups and there is what's called a
poker identity game.
You know which,
which identity group has larger
victimology and greater grievances and
the top group that you really can't
touch our,
our people of the Muslim faith.
What about Islamic transgender male
feminist that that's.
That's the royal flush.
That's you're holding the royal flush
right there.
You're a fucking.
Yeah,
you can't be beat and you've got five
jokers at my university and my
university right now in Montreal.
At one point I sat precisely because
people had a sense of some of the
positions I held.
They asked me to come in and sit on a
religious accommodation committee.
We're a secular university in a secular
society officially as the official law.
So what does it mean to say that we're
going to now enact a religious
accommodation policy?
I mean that's like saying I am a virgin
but I'm pregnant.
I mean it's really the term can't make
sense how.
Right.
So my position was I am equally non
pliant to anybody's religious beliefs.
If Jews come to my class and say,
we want to do young people,
blah,
well I'm Jewish and I'm still going to
come to the lecture,
but now if Moslems come and say we want
to take Hash for three weeks at Mecca so
we won't be showing up to your class for
three weeks.
Well,
I'm equally unreceptive that idea.
it seemed like most people were pretty
happy with my general position as long
as it didn't apply to this one
particular group.
Now that suicidal,
right?
That can't be because that's already
institutionalizing the fact that people
are not all equal.
Right?
Some people deserve more accommodations
than others.
That's dangerous.
Right?
That's so in the US.
Freedom of religion also includes,
as you know.
I mean it's a cliche.
Freedom from religion,
be religious,
just don't put it in my face,
but I think in our desperate desire to
constantly accommodate people would
going down the wrong path,
but not just constantly accommodate
people,
but accommodate people that are
perceived to have been persecuted,
only not accommodate.
People that have a contrary point of
view,
not debate them or look at them all
objectively true and consider all the
various possibilities.
Have we been incorrect in our thinking?
Is this a possible like the woman that
you were talking about that from
Brandeis.
I mean,
that's,
that's unbelievably shocking for someone
who have gone through something so
horrifying to be escaping running for
their life,
really escaping to America and then to
be called an Islamophobia.
That's right.
And as you said,
who is spearheading that?
The professors and by the way,
Brandeis University,
as you may know,
was founded by a liberal a lot by
brandeis who was trying to kind of found
an institution that would be open to all
that would be pluralistic precisely
because of some of the antisemitism that
Jewish students would have faced at some
of the sort of northeastern schools.
And so the school is founded on these
principles.
And then at the first opportunity you
violate everything that you stand for.
Is there any movement to try to change
this?
Is there any discussion to try to,
uh,
this sort of real issue with academia as
well?
If I can be a modest,
I think it's guys like me who are
trying,
who are really in the wilderness who try
to come out of the woodworks and have
the courage and the big festivals to try
to do that,
but I think most people have heard
instinct,
but even if you say that you have the
testicles to do this,
how dare you.
You can't do this with ovaries.
Is that what you're saying?
I apologize for having said that.
I have testicle now.
It's this.
It's an expression of courage.
Women have balls too.
I know a lot of checks with balls if you
look at it that way,
but it's unfortunate that a woman has to
hear that and go,
oh well,
great.
It's associated with male gender have.
Well that's true,
but if a guy is a great guy,
oh,
that guy's the tits.
I mean that is something that people say
to like my friend Steve,
he says every everything is good.
He calls titties titties movie man.
Like I used to be a competitive soccer
player and the kind of trash talking
that would happen as,
as you would know your athlete is
astounding.
The things that would be sad for example
of calling you some homophobic slur name
go to move,
right?
Or,
or calling you.
I mean,
I remember at one point I played in the
league called the Black Lake where you
would only to not to non black guys.
I was one of them and so they,
you know,
I would if somebody with tackling and
say,
you know,
stop whining,
get up white bitch right now in today's
now.
Usually the way I fought that as I say,
I'm not going to get by this guy next
time around and I'm going to score a
goal.
I didn't kind of curl into a fetal
position.
Start crying.
Well today they are.
I mean facetiously that are commissar
standing around the field,
making sure that nobody,
others,
any of these slur words because then you
could be taken to hate speech code
tribunal mean in Canada.
We have hate speech laws.
They.
How could that be?
Now,
of course,
I'm not suggesting that we should all be
insulting one another and of course we
should all be kind and gentle to each
other,
but the idea that if you tell me a white
bitch,
I could actually impose upon you to go
to a hate speech tribunals is
astounding.
I mean,
what?
What's freedom of speech?
Freedom of speech is the right to also
be an asshole.
Correct.
And,
but unfortunately now everything is
sanitized.
Everything is just freedom of speech is
the right to be an asshole.
But on,
in other terms,
freedom of speech,
on the other hand,
in response to your being an asshole is
the right to ostracize you like the
right to get you out of social groups
and that's how you recognize asphalts
exactly,
but when you sanitize the world and
remove half the language and put trigger
warnings out for everything that
everybody says,
it's very difficult to get to the heart
of what someone's trying to communicate,
right?
When we're making mouth noises,
trying to express our thoughts.
And we're limited in such an amazing way
by so many different forms of
expression.
Well,
a,
here's a great example that's happening
all over the West and certainly in
Canada and the US try to give a lecture
or invite somebody either that has a pro
Israel position or an anti Islam
position and go to UC Irvine and see
what happens.
Uh,
the,
the former ambassador of Israel tried to
come and give a lecture and I mean,
it wasn't an incendiary thing.
He wasn't going to be saying some
horribly controversial things and yet
they tried to shut them down.
Benjamin Netanyahu,
the current prime minister of Israel was
shut down at my university.
Wow.
At Concordia University in Montreal,
the Prime Minister of a democratic
elected government are only supposed to
true ally in the Middle East was unable
to speak because there was great a
threat of danger.
Now that's a v astonishingly dangerous,
right?
I mean,
if,
if that guy can't speak,
probably you and I are not going to have
much of a voice.
There was a university in Toronto,
I forget which one,
but there was a speech by a guy who was
considered to be a men's rights advocate
with the,
the,
the insult as they call them Mras and he
had written a book and he was giving the
speech and these feminists were
protesting and York University was at
York.
I think it was your and violent
opposition and what he had,
what they had said that he said and what
he actually said.
It was so completely diametrically op.
I mean was so incorrect that it was
almost like they'd never read what he
had said.
They had just decided that this was a
target because he was a.
He was an example.
He was a figurehead of the patriarchy
and so they.
These people were showing up for these
lectures like,
look,
I,
like I said,
I read websites that I don't agree with.
I watch a republican debates.
I watch.
I watched these bizarre Republican Fox
News talk shows where they have these
insane views of the world.
I don't agree with them.
I watch it because I'm fascinated.
I watch it because I want to know what
this knucklehead thinks about,
you know,
God and climate change.
God has a great sense of humor.
You know,
look the world,
have we.
We played a video the other day of a
woman who's.
She's running for Congress.
It's crazy bitch.
She,
she was.
She said,
I can prove there's no global warming
with a simple tool,
a thermometer,
and she pulls it out like I'm fascinated
by that lady.
I will watch that lady talk.
It doesn't mean I'm.
I agreed with her.
So these,
these feminists is radical feminists as
it were.
Whatever your radical.
Anyway,
anything we usually an idiot,
but these radical feminists,
we're keeping people from attending
this.
Not just the people that were speaking,
you know,
they weren't protesting the people that
were speaking,
they were screaming and yelling at the
people they're trying to go into,
listen to this person talk,
agree or disagree.
The idea that you are trying to oppose
or trying to stop you are in opposition
of a person listening to a contrary
point of view.
That's amazing.
Well,
I already dangerous,
very dangerous.
I wrote an article on my psychology
today blog,
uh,
maybe about two years ago where this
wasn't my study.
I was just simply summarizing somebody
else's work,
what he had basically done,
or I think there were several
researchers,
they had looked at the political
leanings of professors at American
universities,
uh,
whether they're Democrat or Republican
and they actually then broke it down by
departments.
So for example,
what would be the Democrat versus
Republican ratio in sociology versus in
physics?
What they found is that I think if I'm
going on memory,
I think that the ratio is about five to
one Democrat to Republican and in some
departments,
most notably,
for example,
in the humanities and sociology and so
on,
it was 44 to one.
Now I,
I,
I didn't present this as this is good or
this is bad,
but I certainly was trying to make the
point that on some issues that's not a
good idea.
For example,
what should be fiscal policy,
um,
you know,
what should be our position regarding
immigration.
Uh,
uh,
what,
what is the position regarding the death
penalty?
These are not clear sort of
scientifically,
you know?
Right.
I mean,
it depends.
And to have a sanitized campus,
we're only one group of people really
dominate.
I thought was dangerous.
You should've seen the blowback.
I got there.
Now,
the only thing that protects me in such
situations is that being Canadian,
I could say these things without
appearing as though I have a dog in the
fight.
Hey,
I'm not Democrat,
I'm Republican Canadian,
so I must be unbiased and in a sense
they'll give me a bit of a get out of
jail card because I.
It doesn't appear as though I'm fighting
for one or the other,
but still the blow back was astonishing
because how dare I point to this as
though it were a bad thing.
I mean,
everybody knows that every Democrat is
perfect on everything and every
Republican is an idiot,
you know,
toothless evolution,
denying buffoon.
And that strikes me as astonishing from
otherwise intelligent people.
The world is more nuanced,
right?
There are many issues on which I agree
with Democrats as a Canadian.
They are a few issues on which I
actually agree more with Republicans.
Uh,
and so I kind of pick and choose my
battles,
but that's not how it is in academia,
but in their defense though,
the points that are taken by the
Republicans so often are there really,
if you had to choose,
like one side that's paying attention to
science and one side that's paying
attention to religion,
it's pretty clear except well listen,
and I'm going to have solutionist.
So obviously when it's going to come on
that issue,
I'm going to be a lot more with the
Democrats then all the.
But for example,
my position,
you may disagree.
I hope you don't kick me out of here.
I will never take you out of your very
kind of the death penalty.
I think that if you are having raped and
killed 10 children and we've got the DNA
of,
of you on the potential,
it's incontrovertible that you are
guilty.
Uh,
I don't see it as a terrible moral issue
that we could potentially discuss the
possibility of executing you.
As a matter of fact,
I think that in some cases,
the amount of rights that we give to
otherwise horrifying monsters,
that itself is barbaric.
So on that dimension,
I'm likely to be much more quote
Republican and I am as well.
I agree with you 100 percent.
So know nuance thinking is as a mark of
somebody who kind of has a sense of what
the world looks like.
And I think that that's also a mark of
someone who doesn't have a dog in the
fight.
As I said before.
I think when you look at the world,
there's a lot of variables that must be
taken into consideration as soon as you
deny those variables because you have a
specific stance.
It's a predetermined pattern of thinking
that you've aligned yourself with.
I'm on the left and as a Democrat,
like I was having a conversation with
someone the other day and they were
talking to you about upcoming elections
and they said if we lose the house,
if we lose,
like he's a fucking comedian.
He's a comedian that I'm talking to and
he's talking about the Democrats and
he's on team.
And I'm like,
wow,
I'm 100 percent for the death penalty in
terms in like a Ted Bundy type
character.
Some monster.
But my problem with it,
my number one problem with it is that I
don't believe that the system is a good
system.
I don't.
I don't believe it's an infallible.
I think there's a lot of issues when it
comes to people who are prosecutors who
deny evidence,
withhold evidence.
They,
they,
they know that they're wrong and they
still arrest people.
They still prosecute people.
This has been so many instances of that.
I can't trust
their judgment.
I can't trust.
There was a video the other day of a man
who's a police officer pulling some
woman she was trying to resist.
He threw it to the ground and he's
beating her,
punching her in the face in,
in Los Angeles,
and as long as that is a part of our
legal system that this,
this guy.
I mean she wasn't fighting back.
He wasn't.
He wasn't fighting for his life.
She was resisting.
I don't know what the circumstances
were,
but whatever I know is,
if that is the only way you can handle
that woman,
you shouldn't be a police officer.
And as ridiculous,
as long as that exists,
that's part of our legal system.
That's just a human flaw that exists on
all levels that will exist as far as a
police officer who's on the street that
will exist as far as a prosecutor,
as a judge,
a person running a prison.
There's going to be human flaws and the
entire system.
And that's the only reason why I
hesitate as far as.
But in that sense,
yeah,
I'm way more Republican than I am
Democrat.
I,
I tell you a story about a sort of
police misconduct,
uh,
many years ago I had met a guy who would
serve as a public defender in the La
county system.
And as we were chatting,
you know,
I was very interested in all of this
stuff that he had to say.
He said to me,
one advice I could give you is don't
ever do anything in California that will
have you end up in La County jail.
And I said,
Oh,
why's that?
I said,
give me an example of why would somebody
like me.
He goes,
let's suppose you were a recidivist
drink and drive kind of guy,
and the cops are pissed off at you.
They'll take you to the jail,
they'll throw you with all the
gangbangers and they'll simply scream
out fresh fish out of water.
That's exactly the term that he used,
which basically is the code word for
have that in boys and we won't,
we won't hurt here.
His screams and,
and I remember this,
this,
this isn't in the late eighties.
And subsequently I actually met the son
of the sky coincidentally and later
found out that that was his father by
quincy.
He was an academic also.
But anyway,
so that's,
that's an example of misconduct where,
you know,
if you piss off these gaps,
they could do all sorts of things to you
that can have some profound consequences
on your body.
Yeah.
I just want to state for the record,
I'm a big supporter of law enforcement.
Always have been one bad cop is not cops
make bad,
make all cops are bad.
Humans were flawed,
you know,
not every,
not every doctor is a good person.
I mean,
I have a friend who used to work when he
was younger,
he worked at a resort and he said he
would overhear these doctors very
specifically remembered overhearing
these doctors bragging about talking
this guy into a surgery and about how
he's going to buy a car now,
you know,
like,
uh,
that's a,
that's a new whatever it was,
porsche,
whatever.
For me,
you know,
this.
And he was bragging about talking to
this kind of surgery.
Incredible.
Yeah,
I mean,
that's real.
That does happen.
You know,
there there's bad people in all walks of
life and I think that that is my number,
my only really resistance to something
like the death penalty.
But when you look at the recidivism
rates for child rapists,
it's just through the roof.
It's crazy.
I don't know if you've seen the stat I,
and I can't cite who came up with it,
but uh,
apparently when you catch a pedophile,
he's on average committed 100
transgressions prior to you catching him
for the first time.
Right.
So,
so why does this guy benefit from all of
our legals?
I mean it,
you know,
it.
If you've done this stuff so many times,
why do we have to be humane?
I would actually argue it's inhumane to
be so human to this guy,
and I wrote an article on on psychology
today where I was talking about,
I don't know if you remember the case
with the two guys in Connecticut who did
a home invasion and they raped the girls
and the mother and set the house on
fire,
beat the father,
but he survived and so on and so it was
coming up to their death penalty and so
I sort of as a tribute to that case,
I wrote a,
an article on my psychology today blog,
which I think I titled is the Death
Penalty Barbaric and I was arguing that
in for these kinds of guys.
No,
it's not.
While you should have seen my
progressive enlightened cafe sipping
academic colleagues scoff at my barber
isn't right.
What kind of Hick must it be to actually
even hold those sentences?
Well,
I got news for you,
man.
If it comes between,
put me in jail for the rest of my life
and some cage where I have to be
constantly in fear of men raping me and
stabbing me with tooth parses,
sharp knives.
I'll take death exactly that way and I
think we should all,
if there's no,
no possible,
reasonable hope for parole.
The idea of keeping someone to jail and
a jail to rot for the rest of their life
is probably more subtle.
More cruel.
Exactly.
Yeah.
It's just bizarre.
The idea that that's,
that's somehow or another humane is so
crazy and a lot of them,
by the way,
solitary confinement,
which is probably one of the worst
things that you could do to a person,
especially a social,
a social analyst person.
People were weird.
We need to be connected so much and one
of the worst punishments you could do it
just leave us alone while we're in
prison,
surrounded by murderers,
rapists,
thieves,
thugs,
drug dealers.
The worst thing they can do is put you
by yourself.
That's exactly right.
Amazed that there's a guy,
I don't remember his name,
a Harvard,
a professor who had studied,
uh,
you know,
what makes people healthy for,
for something like 60 years.
And I think the bottom line,
if I'm paraphrasing him,
is that people need social relationships
to be healthy.
That's sort of the number one thing that
maintains your health,
psychological and physiological
and happy social relationships to
exactly.
I mean,
I,
everyone that I know that has these
horrible relationships with either
boyfriends and girlfriends or with their
parents or with their job or the like,
they seem to like carry those on like
all the time.
It's like becomes almost a part of the
norm of.
But
the people that I know that have healthy
relationships with their boyfriends and
girlfriends or wives and husbands,
healthy relationships with their
children,
friends,
those are the happiest people I know,
right?
Like you can't,
you could foster that and you can
somehow or another j generate this sort
of beautiful environment around the
closest people to you.
You'll have a much better life.
It's just that simple.
And by the way,
evolutionary psychologists study all of
these kinds of things,
uh,
you know,
why is it that we would jump into a
river to save two brothers or better
yet,
why would we jump into a river to save a
stranger?
And,
and it,
it,
it boils down to the fact that it's tit
for tat,
right?
It's what's called reciprocal altruism
a.
are you familiar with this?
So,
so someone will do that for you someday.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And so the idea that,
you know,
as you said that it's a real punishment
that put people in confinement is borne
out by evolutionary theory.
My friend Rammi jumped into a river to
save a woman.
She,
uh,
she was in a canoe canoe,
flipped over,
husband drowned.
The husband's body floated face first
passed him and the woman was screaming,
help me,
and he saw he saw her in the river and
he just dove in and he's lucky.
He's in incredible shape and he's an
outdoorsman and he's there.
He's a very good athlete,
very good sweater.
He's got real good endurance.
So he got to death's door,
like literally on death's door,
thought it was over,
thought it,
he's not going to make it out of here,
like he just sacrificed his life trying
to save this woman and then rescued,
or they figured out a way to shore.
But when he describes the feeling and
the experience,
it was almost beyond his control.
It was like he saw this woman.
It was only him.
There was no one else there.
He had to do it and just jumped in.
While there's this thing,
speaking of guys who are in the business
of doing heroic acts,
there's a,
you've heard of the fireman fantasy.
I mean that the fact that women find
guys bought firemen to be very
attractive and it actually turns out
that there was a study that was done
that actually shows us to be the case.
And I have discussed this in one of my
articles on psychology today.
If you have a guy approach women either
wearing a fireman,
sooth or not,
uh,
his chances of getting her phone number
increases quite substantially.
Really if he is wearing a fireman.
So how do they know this?
Did they do a study guide?
Where do they have the same guy?
Not where the firemen with the same
approach and the same.
Same word,
same scripts,
same everything.
One version.
It's called the field experiment.
In one version you,
you approach women at a cafe wearing the
stuff and another version you don't.
The Guy who actually did that research
is a French psychologist.
His name is Nicola Guy and I've actually
covered a few of his studies on my
website,
my most read article ever over maybe
three,
400,000
readers as is one of his studies where I
was sympathetic because we're going to
talk about the blowback issue now here
again,
it was a study where he looked at the
likelihood
of women being picked up as hitchhikers
as a function of their breast size.
So he actually had the same woman and
they artificially manipulated her breast
size and on different days she would
stand there.
And and of course it turned out that men
were much more likely to pick up the
woman if she had the same woman that she
had bigger breast side.
So I just summarize that study,
put it up,
and then I remember I had gone on
vacation,
came back from vacation father that I
had to completely gone viral,
but I had a million hate mail,
not just from readers,
but from fellow psychologists that they
bloggers who were arguing that I was
peddling pornography because I had a
picture as the teaser image for that
article.
I had a photo of a woman sitting in a
passenger seat,
would big wood,
large breasts.
Well,
it seemed appropriate for the topic
given that that's what the topic of the
study was.
But by putting that image I was
objectifying women.
I was treating them as sex objects.
And so even though I had nothing to do
with the study and I was simply
summarizing somebody else's work,
I was a horrifying pornographic
pedaling.
Isn't it funny that just a photograph of
a woman with large breasts is considered
pornographic
right?
Now,
listen to this.
So then I've also written articles on
psychology today where I talk about all
kinds of issues dealing with penis size.
You know,
so do women want a guy with a bigger
penis?
Are they more likely to have orgasms?
She's got a bigger penis.
Uh,
if you're in a gay relationship,
man,
are you likely to be top or bottom as a
function of your penis size?
That study has been done by science,
and so for those articles I put sexy
images of men.
So then I wrote to each of those people
who had written the hate man.
I said,
well,
in all fairness,
you now have to write an equally hateful
thing because I'm also sexually
exploiting men's bodies.
Of course they went away and never came
back.
Yeah,
well,
the idea being that women are more
oppressed than men are not equal,
but it is equal.
It's very tricky,
but the idea that a woman with big
breasts sitting there and I passed her
seat of a car,
could somehow or another be
pornographic.
It was ridiculous.
Yeah.
Women have big breasts,
so some of them they exists.
I'm in a big penises.
It all.
It's all real stuff.
Some people have two eyes and noses.
Interestingly,
some of the
college,
these are psychologists were saying,
why do you write about these issues of
sexuality?
What does that have to do with
psychology?
Why are you so,
so that psychologists could actually
argue that issues dealing with sexuality
were outside the purview of psychology.
That's.
Well,
it's stupid.
It's really,
it's scary stupid because it's denying
reality in order to fit with your
ideology.
This ideology of politically correct
thinking.
And I don't like the term politically
correct.
I don't like it because it's been sort
of overrun
and overused and it's kind of like,
it's a beaten term,
right?
You know,
but it's the appropriate one just to
convey the idea.
Right.
But it's just,
it's so prevalent,
it's so prevalent and that the fact that
it's so prevalent amongst academics is
really disturbing to me.
Yeah.
I'm with you,
you know,
have you had,
have you had many other academics on the
show quite a bit.
What's,
how are they like in terms of their
general positions?
Um,
well,
many,
many of them share your points of view.
Oh really?
Luckily.
Now is it just that you happen to
gravitate towards guys that you would
think that already would sort of not be
these little wimpy guys or,
or.
I mean,
how come it turns out that they're all
sharing because we're certainly in the
minority in academia,
so those are the only ones I'm
interested in.
I guess.
I mean,
I'm actually quite fascinating talk.
I would love to talk to some male
feminist who shares these Islamic phobic
hating ideas,
like hating Islamophobia,
and I'll send you,
I'll send you some names.
What the problem is,
you know,
it would get ugly somewhere along the
line,
right?
You know,
I'm sure one of us would resort to
insults not.
I wouldn't be.
I wouldn't put.
I am utterly fascinated by ideology,
ideologies that I support or do not
support,
you know,
all of them.
I mean,
I,
I'm fascinated by the Dalai Lama.
I'm fascinated by how many people take a
guy who only wears orange robe.
Seriously.
Come on.
Do you really think God gives a fuck
what clothes you wear?
Is He,
is he staying warm in that or is he.
He's no different than that fucking Phil
Robertson Guy.
That's from duck dynasty.
Always worse.
Cammo was wearing a God damn outfit and
buy that outfit.
You recognize that he,
oh,
he's a man of peace and of enlightened
thinking.
No,
he's a silly man who wears orange,
doesn't have sex.
Okay.
And why does he not have sex?
Because he has an ideology,
right?
This ideology tells him that he's a holy
man from birth.
And if you don't think that's fucking
ridiculous because he's friends with
Sharon stone.
You and I have nothing to talk about.
Oh,
he's,
he's buddies with Richard Gere.
He must be holy.
You get the fuck Outta here,
man.
You know,
it's funny you talk about these
Hollywood types.
I wrote an article which one of those
really popular ones on psychology today
when I was talking about the narcissism
and grandiosity of celebrities were,
uh,
they,
what's her madonna because of her cabala
juice,
uh,
says that,
the radiation problem and some lake in
Ukraine could be resolved by putting
some cabala juice on it.
And she's really,
she's really astounding.
Come on,
wait a minute.
Kabbalah Kabbalah.
Holy Water.
I don't know anyone.
I don't want to help her in any way by
bringing this up.
And,
you know,
when Paul had some other thing about
beauty,
uh,
the,
um,
the autism girl,
everything.
Oh,
Jenny McCarthy,
the autism was,
was shocked that the NIH,
the Institute of Health was
not taking her scientific research
seriously demonstrating that that's what
she has.
Scientists know she does research.
She,
I think she must've played once at some
point.
No,
but seriously,
what I argue there is that,
uh,
you know,
if you're,
if you're walking all day with yes men
catering to each of your whims,
you actually live in a world where you
truly start thinking that you're data.
I mean,
you really did save the world.
I'm Tom Cruise and I saved the world in
mission impossible,
whatever,
and therefore it is perfectly reasonable
that I have something profound to say
about everything right there for Tom
Cruise says that there is no such thing
as psych,
psychiatric instant illnesses.
You just have to do exercise and
vitamins and that we don't take that
seriously is really an affront to him.
And so I had written an article where I
was saying that it's,
it's really astounding the type of
narcissism that these folks and I argued
that it is part,
it comes from a form of guilt that deep
in the recesses of their bedrooms,
when they turn off the lights,
many of them actually know that they are
frauds that are not really deserving of
all of the perks that they've received.
And so one of the ways that maybe I
could fix that is by demonstrating that
I am much more than a mere actor.
I'm really helping in Darfur.
I'm really helping solve the radiation
problem in the Ukraine and so on and so
forth.
Because then I seem as though maybe I am
more worthy of all the accolades that
are being bestowed upon me.
That's a very fascinating way of looking
at it.
I think you probably are onto something
there.
I think the knowledge and the
understanding that they're frauds,
the deep seated knowledge,
whether they avoid it and deny it or
not.
I there's a lot of people that are
horrible people that are involved in
charitable organizations and one of the
reasons being is to church sort of show
that they are good people.
There's a guy who's a pretty blatant
plagiarist who's involved in some pretty
interesting charities for good
charities,
very good charities,
but I had a conversation with someone
about it and they were talking about,
hey,
you know what?
He does so much good for this
organization.
I don't.
I don't care.
I go,
do you understand that?
That's probably why he does that.
Like the guy's a complete sociopath.
He's fucked over his friends.
You stolen their work and pass it off as
his own.
Yet he supports firefighters.
Do you not understand that that's what's
going on there?
I mean,
he's pretty obvious.
If you listen to him talk for any long
period of time,
there's something wrong.
There's like some some connections
inside the mind that are not being made
and he's had a strategy and a strategy
to avoid criticism is to show charitable
work.
Like Lance Armstrong,
whenever he was confronted about his
drug use,
would always talk about how much he's
doing for cancer,
for cancer research.
That was this whole thing,
despite the fact that he'd sued people
that had claimed that they,
their lives had been affected by his
drug use,
that they,
the people that they love had been
drug tested and that they,
you know,
they lost their whole entire career and
that they were aligned with Lance
Armstrong did drugs with Lance
Armstrong,
Lance Armstrong would sue these people,
you know,
you're in La.
And then finally came out and told the
truth and you know,
passed off as organization to other
people.
Now he's a fucking broken man and
rightly so because he's a God damn
sociopath.
But that this instance or this
insistence rather of being a part of a
charitable organization and being the
figurehead,
not just silently like I don't,
I,
I'm a big fan of not talking about
charities that I contribute to.
I don't like to.
Because I think there's something sneaky
about.
It's almost like it,
like if you give a thousand dollars to a
charity,
but then you let everybody know,
hey,
I just get a thousand dollars to a
charity.
I talk about that in my books.
Yeah.
So there's something there.
You know what my money.
This is an old philosophy,
Jewish philosopher from the twelfth
century.
He's very,
very important guy in Jewish moral
philosophy at.
He talked about eight levels of said
that cuts is charity giving.
Uh,
in terms of the purity of the act,
the most pure form of Tzedakah is where
the altruist and the recipient of the
altruism don't know of one another
because,
and he said this a thousand years ago
where he had no evolutionary attorney,
but I then I then package it as,
as an evolutionary argument because
there's great social signaling rewards
that come from you writing the Joe Rogan
cancer ward,
right?
Right.
If you are in,
why do the upper uppers don't drive
maseratis because everybody in their
circle can also buy a Maserati.
So they actually drive pretty oftentime,
pretty cheapest cars because that's not
going to be a very honest signal of my
true value because everybody in my
social group can imitate it,
but if I can give $100,
million dollars to the soul and so
cancer or buy a $100,
million dollar painting that a two year
old could,
could have otherwise painted.
Boy,
that's an honest signal of my quality.
Right.
And so I actually talk about this exact
idea of,
of not advertising your generosity.
Yeah.
I call it happiness bombs.
When I leave a big tip at a restaurant,
I get out of there before the waiter
could see what the Ta is nice.
I like to do that.
I like to leave big tips and then run
the fuck out of there.
I don't want to see that person.
I say thank you to them on the way out
the door,
but I don't want to see the tip and then
thank me back because it almost like,
you know,
it takes away from it.
It's like,
like I said,
if someone donates a thousand dollars
but then tells the world they do a
$1,000,
I think you owe another thousand
dollars,
you'll,
you'll always silent thousand.
Do you know the,
you know,
you must know the show curb your
enthusiasm.
Yes.
So there's an episode on Tuesday,
Asm,
where Larry David is at some function
with Ted Danson.
They both gave anonymous donations,
but everybody keeps walking up to that
dance and telling you,
oh,
congratulations on this donation.
That was so generous of you.
So Larry,
David go.
David goes crazy because he goes,
that's bullshit,
man.
You're from this whole thing.
It's not anonymous.
Nobody knows that.
It's exactly what we were talking about.
Right?
So that whole episode was a great
episode because whoever wrote it
actually understands our human nature.
Yeah.
It's a fascinating,
fascinating aspect of human beings.
This,
this need to be considered altruistic.
Yes.
Need to be considered benevolent.
You know the to to advertise it instead
of just being,
you know that you can't exist in the
silence of the personal satisfaction of
contributing and giving,
giving out love and generosity that you
have to be rewarded for it.
Well,
I have a section in my first book which
I titled Philanthropy as a costly
signal,
constantly signaling and biology.
So the Peacock's tail is a constantly
signal because it actually serves as a
really honest signal of my worth for me
to carry this burden,
tail and avoid predators.
Then you really should take me seriously
all you female hands because here I am
here and I've survived.
So that's called an honest signal or a
costly sigma.
Well,
philanthropy I argue in many cases is
that us on a signal?
Precisely for the reasons that we're
talking about.
So I am fascinated by peacocks.
I'm fascinated by black guys who go to
clubs with $100,000
worth of jewelry on them.
You know,
I,
it's amazing that,
that aspect of,
especially the rap community.
Well,
you know,
the,
the throwing the money and all the
videos.
I'm making sure I got an article on
that,
man.
Did you ever think that you would have a
scientist on your show talking about the
evolutionary roots of making it rain?
Oh No.
I'm so happy to be talking to you now.
I was happy to talk to you already,
but now more so,
um,
what is,
what is that like the,
the,
the diamonds and the gold chains.
And then why is it specifically
connected to the African American
community as opposed to you?
I mean,
the Italian American community was
always gold chains a little bit,
but not as much diamonds and mean black
people took it to a totally new level.
Right?
I,
I can't speak to why one culture,
the sides to use one particular form of
status.
If you're the mass tribe in Africa,
it might be the number of cattle heads
that you have.
That is the peacocking,
right?
So what we do know is that different
cultures will use different forms of
peacocking,
but in all cultures it is going to be
the males in that culture who engage in
the act.
That's the universal,
the peacock in the African American
community is most fascinating because a
lot of these rappers come from these
very poor neighborhoods,
so they're dealing with a lot of poverty
and crime and as they're growing up,
and then as they get older,
their identities,
once they become connected to success
are also connected to firearms and and
diamonds.
Specifically diamonds.
They're all day blinged out everything
out teeth.
Yeah.
How crazy is that?
You're walking around with 100,000
dollars with a dental appliances.
I mean probably more.
I don't understand diamonds,
so I don't.
I don't own any diamonds,
so when I say 100,000
dollars,
I don't.
I might be way off.
There was a company called,
I don't remember the name of the
company,
but the project was called American
brand stand.
A play on American bandstand.
Dick Clark,
they collect a.
So what they did is they did they,
they looked,
they did a content analysis of brand
mentions in billboard top 100 to see how
often brands are mentioned.
Hey girl,
I've got the Maserati.
And what they found,
not surprisingly,
is that it's almost exclusively in hip
hop videos.
It's almost exclusively male rappers who
do this behavior.
And it wasn't diamonds,
actually,
what the number one product was,
cars.
So cars were overwhelmingly the most
often cited form of peacocking in rap
video,
in rap songs.
I was at a,
uh,
an event,
a kickboxing event in Los Angeles.
All my friends,
Eddie and tate,
and we,
uh,
we,
we showed up.
This guy pulled up in this bright orange
Lamborghini,
this crazy car with a gold wing doors
that pop up.
And uh,
I,
we were talking and I'm a fan of cars.
I love cars,
but I do not like lamborghinis.
I think they're foolish.
I think the doors are foolish.
I mean they break all the time.
I have a friend who reviews cars and he
reviewed this Lamborghini aventador and
he said it broke down after like two
days ahead of,
for two days.
And the transmission exploded.
And I was laughing about it and I was
like,
what the fuck?
Like why would you spend a half a
million dollars on that car?
Like there's some brilliant pieces of.
I'm a big fan of cars.
I'm a big fan of engineering in general.
I love well engineered watches.
I love a well engineered table.
I love lapped fastened.
I'm fascinated by human innovation.
So when I see certain cars I am
fascinated by them,
but when I see that one,
I just think that's just so goofy and my
friends were like,
Bro,
that car gets you posted.
And I was like,
really?
He doesn't really like come on man is a
girl.
What a girl bank.
So we had this debate with a girl,
have sex with you.
She saw you in that car.
Let me answer that.
As opposed to please do as opposed to
let's say a corvette and like,
Nah man,
anybody can get a corvette.
The corvette is like,
my friend goes,
man,
a girl will hop in your car just to see
where you live.
If you have that car,
they just want to see what your house.
You've got a $500,000
car.
What the fuck does that do to the house?
Look like south?
Tell you three scientific studies,
one of which is mine,
and then a personal story of my brother
who lives in southern California.
Uh,
so Nico,
I get down to the guy who did the breast
and French guy,
a French guy that did a study,
a very much similar in spirit where
instead of manipulating the firemen
sooth,
he had the same guy approach different
women as a function of an manipulated
which car he was driving.
I can't remember the exact details,
but something like a three time increase
and the likelihood of a woman giving you
her phone number if you are driving high
status car versus a little status car
that's exactly three times three times
greater.
Wow.
And the same guy by the way,
that another study
where he.
Yah,
he was either he made the guy who was
approaching the woman was either with a
baby or not,
and another version with a dog or not
having a dog increases digits uptake,
invention and have interacting with the
baby also increases.
So I joke that you should be driving a
Lamborghini while having a dog next to
you and it baby while wearing a
fireman's suit.
You're going to get all the ladies in
Orange County and in Newport beach,
so that's one and another study,
and then I'm going to come to my study
in the second and another study,
not by this guy.
They took the same men,
put them either in a Bentley or in a
whatever,
Ford Fiesta and did the same thing with
the same with a wound and then it those
opposite sex rating so the women would
rate the two guys and the same guy when
he is in the Bentley,
was viewed as astonishingly more
handsome.
Which of course objectives can be.
I mean you have your physiology.
If your physical traits don't change,
but there was a glow effect from the car
that he's driving.
He's handsome,
he's,
he's a Brad Pitt and this car.
He's a loser in this other car,
but the same manipulation on women.
Men didn't care.
In other words,
their evaluations of how attractive the
woman was.
That not depend on which car she was
seated in,
so
I would think that with men and with
women that the women,
it would be more intimidating to the men
if the women drove a Bentley all because
they have status perhaps.
Well especially if you have a Toyota,
some crappy,
nice car,
Toyota,
you know,
not a bad car but just not a high status
car.
But if you pulled up in a,
you know,
whatever,
name it,
Chevy,
cobalt or something like that and the,
you know,
the girl you're going to go on a date
with,
pulls up in a Lamborghini like,
ah,
what the fuck.
Right.
I would think that for some men they
find that someone,
men find women that are very successful,
intimidating here.
They were just,
they were just asking them how good
looking do you think they are?
So specific to physical attraction.
Okay.
Yeah.
So the.
Yeah,
I would say the physical attraction
wouldn't change,
but I would say that the desire to
approach that person or the willingness
to approach that person.
I'm with you.
Yeah.
I think,
uh,
women with,
with like a really expensive car would
be intimidating.
Third Study and then the personal story
from my brother,
uh,
I did a study a few years ago where I
brought.
This was a former graduate student of
mine.
We brought people into the lab and then
we rented a porsche.
This wasn't imagined.
You're driving a porsche.
We actually rented a Porsche and as I,
as I tell one of my ted talks,
try to get a,
a granting agency to release money to do
research where you're going,
where you're saying we're saying I'm
going to rent a porsche for the weekend
as part of my research.
So,
uh,
we rented a Porsche and then we had some
other beaten up car and we had the same
men drive both cars either in downtown
Montreal on a Friday evening where
everybody could see you driving the car
or on a semi desert highway where nobody
could see you.
And at the end of each of the driving
conditions,
we collected salivary assets to then
measure their fluctuating levels of
testosterone.
And the idea being that when you put
them in the Porsche,
it's going to explode and that's exactly
what we found.
And now one of the reviewers had
written,
he said,
what?
How do you know that that's just not
because they're driving fast.
And so that's causing a rise in
testosterone.
And the way we could control for that is
an downtown Montreal on a Friday
evening.
It's bumper to bumper traffic.
It's,
I mean it's,
it's,
it's like being in a parking lot,
so it's certainly not because you were
driving fast.
It's because everybody could see that I
am sitting in a porsche.
So you're endocrinological system
exploded simply because of this imbuing
of social status to you.
And we know this from other animals
where if you and I fight,
if we're two males,
we fight.
If you win,
your testosterone goes up.
If I lose my testosterone goes down.
And so here we were applying this exact
idea to the consumer setting.
So the person that was in the fast car
that was on all deserted stretch of
highway just going fast.
Their testosterone didn't rise.
No,
it did.
It did.
We actually
predicted that it would rise in both
those conditions,
but it would rise more when there's a
public audience to see you doing it.
That makes sense.
What we found is that irrespective of
the environment,
you put a young male and a Porsche,
has endocrinological system explodes at
the.
So the environment didn't matter.
Just the fact that you are interviewing
me with this immediate social status,
uh,
resulted in the same increase in
testosterone.
Well,
there isn't it also an engine thing too
with young men.
I know that they've done studies where
they had young men rev engines just like
a v eight,
a powerful va.
Just the sound of that increases
testosterone,
increases testosterone.
I think.
I know that study.
You ain't gonna need to send me that.
Yeah,
I will as soon as I find it.
Um,
but the,
the,
the test that you give them,
how much of a variable or how much of a
variance was there between not driving
that car and driving that car
statistically significant.
So it was certainly strong enough to
pick up a big difference from the toyota
to the other car.
Do you remember the percentage?
I don't know.
I could send you the paper would be big
for athletes.
Just drive around in a fast car.
It'd be good for your recovery because
testosterone with it.
Great.
With my wife and I tell her that since
men as they enter middle age,
their testosterone goes down.
If I now have to buy a luxury car that's
just medically mandated,
well is that what's going on when men
have this midlife crisis,
like that's always the joke with women
that they see a guy in a ferrari and
he's like 50 years old.
Sorry about your penis,
but is that.
Well I did.
I have a study that's not yet published.
Speaking the car.
You
drive in some morphological features,
you're going to like this one.
So this is not published yet.
With one of my former doctoral students,
we actually have.
We created online dating profiles of a
man where everything's the same except
that in one version his prized favorite
position is a fancy red porsche or some
shitty key or whatever it is.
And then we asked men and women who were
looking at this profile to evaluate the
guy's height.
Watch what happened.
Men,
when they evaluate the guy with the
porsche denigrate has height,
shorter women increases height.
This is exactly what you would expect
from an evolutionary perspective,
right?
Sure.
Right status as a threatening queue for
men.
Therefore it serves as an intrasexual
rivalry queue.
So if you are in a fancy car or joe must
be some short,
wimpy guy,
women on the other hand,
we'll look at joe the exact same joe.
He your heIght didn't magically change
and say,
wow,
joe was a tall guy.
Very fascinating.
You should study haters.
It's.
You should study like haters of
celebrities,
like someone who becomes like a justin
bieber type character,
especially someone who's a,
a famous person who women just go like
if justin bieber goes anywhere in
public,
women will literally scream and pass
out.
LIke almost elvis.
Like in some ways he's just study like
what the reaction is to men.
I wonder if there's a latest study that
that is.
That's fascinating to me.
StudYing haters.
That's a good one.
So let me tell you about my,
are we still okay on time?
Yeah,
that's great.
We have an hour.
Oh great.
Uh,
so I have a brother who was living in
California for 30 years at,
who,
by the way I think I'd sent you this
email,
was a fighter,
was a judo olympian,
judo fighter who played in the 19 plate
who competed in the 1976 olympics.
So,
and he used to always say,
by the way,
before it was ever an entity,
I would always ask them if you were in a
fight at a bar against some boxer or
some karate guy who would win,
which was kind of what started the whole
mna thing.
And he used to alwaYs tell me,
oh,
I will destroy them because they might
get one hit on me,
but once I get them,
then once we go down on the ground
there,
they're done.
Uh,
so anyways,
uh,
so he,
he,
he made a lot,
a lot of money in the software industry
in southern California.
And so he used,
he was the classic kind of peacocking
guy.
He owned three ferrari's and aston
martIn lagoon,
the so on and so we would.
He would play this game to,
to,
to my chagrin,
he liked to play this game.
We'd go to a nightclub.
This is before I was married in case my
wife was listening,
but this was before we were married.
We would walk into a bar,
these fancy schmancy clubs,
and he'd say,
take your time and look around and find
the most stunning unattainable in this
space.
Not take yoUr time.
So I'd go around,
look around.
I picked the girl who's not only the
most beautiful,
but the one who is clearly accompanied
by a guy who looks like a brute and they
seem to be very intensely in love.
So now it's.
I've really raised the bar of him not
being able to get her.
Now.
My brother is about five,
four,
three.
So you know,
he's not taught so on.
But boise carrying the big testicles of
owning almost ferrari's.
And so he said,
okay,
that's the goal.
you,
you want me to approach?
Okay.
So the she had to wait like a shark and
then the girl and the guy would go to
the bathroom.
He approached the girl he'd,
he'd come up to about here on her.
I mean,
it was just incredible to watch.
He'd come back to me and say,
she'll call me tomorrow.
I said,
absolutely zero chance.
David's,
it's not going to happen.
Next morning he'd say,
come over here.
It.
At the time we had the answering
machines.
This is like maybe early nineties.
Hi david.
It's candy.
I was,
we met.
Yes.
Well what got him candy?
It was the fact that.
What would you say to them?
I don't know.
I have three ferrari's.
Come with me.
I like the you arabic accent.
I know you have a man,
but he is stupid.
Is big,
but he does not have cars.
But look,
the reality is that whenever we went
anywhere in one of those cars,
I just noticed anecdotally that the
women would be all over the place.
Is that changing with time when people
become more aware of how kind of
peacocky and it becomes more of a
cultural sort of a caricature too?
right.
I think what happens is that the,
the product that we use for the
peacocking might change.
So for example,
maybe in the cafe sipping a parties in
hollywood.
It might be that I drive a prius.
You.
I was so happy you just said that.
Right?
So that now makes me the,
the,
the top dog.
This is actually a paid for by a
colleague of mine,
I think it's called
green to be seen,
which is basically a form of conspicuous
consumption based on being green rather
than being in the big hummer or
whatever.
So the bottom line is that the signal
itself will change,
but the need to signal as a form of a
mating strategy is always they're more
progressive brownie points.
I keep track of the amount of prius's
that I catch throwing cigarettes out the
window.
I'm up to eight,
eight creases in my life.
I have observed throwing cigarettes out
the window.
I get fucking furious because I know
those fucks.
I know what they're doing right?
They dry.
A lot of them drive those things,
not for the consumption,
not for gas,
low keeping gas prices down there doing
it because they want to appear green.
Exactly.
There's actually studies that look at
how much are you willing to pay extra
for a green product and oftentimes what
people say attitudinally and then what
they do if it affects their dollar,
there's a big and continually so you see
the ocracy of people.
Right.
Again,
as the posing,
right?
I mean I want to appear as though I'm
enlightened,
progressive.
I care about mother earth and so.
Well most certainly.
I mean I'm a hunter and I've experienced
this weird thing where people who were
leather and eat meat get angry at you
for hunting and one of the reasons why
they're angry at you for hunting is
somehow or another what you're doing is
animal cruelty that you don't have to do
it.
Why not go to a supermarket?
This was like incredibly narrow minded
way of thinking and I'm like,
you have a leather couch.
Do you understand that?
The animal that you set it on every day
suffered,
unimaginable,
cruel to the animal that I shot,
didn't even know I was there until I put
an arrow through.
It's hard.
Do you ever feel any gumption at doing
it or no?
Yeah.
No.
That definitely.
It's not an easy thing to do.
It's not I,
I eat meat.
I liked me.
I've always eaten meat.
Um,
I've worked out a lot and I find that
I've,
I've tried being a vegetarian once when
I was competing,
um,
back when I was fighting and I didn't
perform as wild and have as much energy
and it feels good and granted,
in all fairness,
my knowledge of nutrition was far less
than than it is now.
And I didn't have the beSt diet in the
world was also very young.
But,
um,
I,
you know,
animals like humans live a finite life
and I think that they eat each other.
They're the world that they live in is.
I'm an unbelievably cruel.
And if it wasn't for getting killed by a
hunter,
it's not like they're going to live
forever and become magic.
Okay.
They,
they get killed by coyotes and mountain
lions and I like going into that world
and acquiring meet.
My goal is at the end of 2014.
All the meat I eat at home to only be
from my hunting.
Okay.
Yeah.
Because I feel like that's the most
ethical way to do this.
I go to different places like I've been,
uh,
I've only been hunting for times.
I shot two deer.
I shot a pig and a wild pig and a shot a
bayer recently,
only animals that I eat,
only animals that I want to eat.
And my freezer is filled with bear meat,
venison and yeah,
I mean,
that's what I,
that's what I try to eat.
I try to eat that.
First of all,
it's super healthy,
you know,
the,
uh,
the animal,
you know,
hasn't been shot up with antibiotics and
hormones.
It's just a natural animal.
And again,
it's living its life in a wild way until
I dip into the food chain and remove it.
But it's not,
it doesn't,
it feels good to accomplish it.
Like the first time I did it,
it was much more somber than it is now.
Now it seems like,
um,
uh,
have sort of accepted what it is and I'm
a much happier after it's over.
I don't,
I don't have this sort of somber
feeling.
the firsT time it was happiness,
but also like,
wow,
it just,
I just took an animal's life.
Big animal,
180 pound deer.
Like this is a lot of,
there's a lot involved in this.
This is real.
But what about,
what's your position?
We're talking about conspicuous
consumption and signaling.
How about trophy hunting?
I don't like that at all.
I have a real problem with that.
Not only Do I have a real problem with
trophy hunting,
I have a real problem with what they're
doing in africa.
These days is a high fence hunting,
but it's very strange.
And here's the contradiction.
Here's where it gets weird.
I had louis theroux.
Do you know who he is?
The documentary and from england,
I'm not sure.
Great guy.
And really fascinating and beautiful
documentary and he's just a really
wonderful documentaries.
And he had this one where he went to
this african hunting camp for several
weeks and stayed there and tried to
really understand what it was all about
and interviewed all these people and a
lot of them were just despicable.
They're just these real hickey people.
Like,
yeah,
I'm just gonna.
Get her.
I'm gonna.
Try to get the big five,
I'm going to get a ride home.
We get an elephant and all they want to
do is spend money and bring home tusks
and horns and all this different shit.
It's pretty gross because it's just
they're killing to acquire trophies and
what they're doing is they're killing
inside these high fences where these
animals,
it's not like you're out there,
you're going to.
And it's not to say that I'm opposed to
high fence hunting because I think if
you're hunting a deer or an animal that
you're just going to eat,
it's essentially a like not that much
different than going to a lake that's
been stocked.
If you're going to a lake and they stock
the lake with trout to ensure that
there's fish to fish,
those fish are not going to get out of
that lake and flied in Nebraska.
Right.
That's where they live.
They're stuck there and I don't think
there's any difference between that,
like these high fence hunting operations
in Texas,
which I don't have any problem with it
all.
They have like these thousand acres in.
One of them I know of is 14,000
acres and they keep deer on it.
And why do they have the fences up?
Well to keep poachers out to keep to.
And they also,
they make a lIving off of guiding people
to hunt these animals.
And for them it's like the ethical,
uh,
acquiring of have your own meat and it's
venison.
It's very delicious.
Tastes good.
It's good for you.
It's very healthy meat.
I don't have a problem with that.
With the african thing is so confusing
because there was a woman recently that
was on the news this past week.
She was 19 years old.
She went to africa and took all these
photos with her than with a lion that
she killed.
I might have shared that on myself,
but that wasn't a week.
Who?
I did one you did recently,
but it was a different one.
I've followed all your stuff for awhile.
Um,
but,
um,
you had you,
you said it's disgusting and she was
holding the mouth.
Yeah,
that's dark.
There's something dark about that man.
I mean,
if you're not going to eat that animal.
I mean I don't.
I have a friend is going lion hunting in
the wild.
He's a bowhunters named cameron hanes.
He's going to eat a lion though.
He's going to go over there.
He's going to hunt it in,
in,
in the.
Not in the high fence.
He's going to Zimbabwe and the actual
jungle.
He's got a hunt,
a lion and he's going to eat it.
You know,
he's fucking crazy to,
to,
to collect salivary assets from these
types of guys.
Pre,
pre,
no post killed.
But he's got.
Oh,
testosterone before and after.
Right.
But I guarantee you that it jumps up
when he,
uh,
she would say he,
he's the one who took me bear hunting.
wow.
Yeah.
He's a,
he's probably one of the most famous bow
hunters in America today,
probably in the world actually.
He's a legit bowhunter.
He makes his living doing that.
And he's a very famous because of the
very ethical though he does not shoot
anything.
He does not eat everything he shoots.
He eats.
And I think that's where,
um,
that's where I have an issue with this,
this,
this africa thing.
But where it gets weird is that those
animals,
many of them were on the verge of
extinction,
but now they are,
they're in very high numbers.
The reason being is that they're in
these events operation.
So it's such a catch 22.
On one hand they were on the verge of
extinction and another hand.
Now they have these high populations and
they're super healthy,
but they only exist as a commodity to be
hunted down.
I mean,
in the way they're doing it was like,
it was a waterhole and there's like 100
animals in front of waterhole.
And these people Just sit there and they
just shoot one.
They'll look what I did on my hun.
Like,
is that even a hunt?
You're in a park.
I mean,
you're in a fenced in for like someone's
yard.
You're not tracking.
You're not only not tracking those
animals,
they're never going to leave and go 100
miles away to a different place.
And then,
you know,
go across the river to mule deer.
They,
they discovered that mule deer in
America.
This is a really recent discovery.
They had no idea how far they migrate,
but they migrate as much as 150 miles in
a year.
One hundred and 50 miles is a lot of
walking man for a deer that's like here
to fucking san diego for a deer,
you know?
And they're just starting to understand
their migratory patterns.
And that's.
But that's a wIld animal.
Now if you,
that's what I consider a fair chase,
right?
You go out hunting,
you find a mule deer that's walking 150
miles,
you figured out where they're going to
be and you know,
and then stalk them and get into a good
position and shoot them and eat them.
So about as fair and ethical way as you
can acquire your own meat if you're
going all the way to africa and you're
not even going to eat that animal.
And he just kinda like stuff it and
stick it on your wall to let everybody
know how billy bad ass you are.
That's weird man.
That's weird aspect of human beings that
we would even consider that to be a form
of recreation,
you know,
and people go,
well,
hey,
it's totally legal and well hey,
there's nothing,
you know,
the,
the money goes to conservation and I
guess it does in a way.
I guess it does.
It does go to keep these animals alive
so they can keep killing them.
It's weird.
It's very weird.
So you have also a paleo Guy.
Well,
you know what,
that whole paleo thing,
I don't like that term paleo because the
term is been debunked by science and you
talked about like what people did or did
not eat.
I think that natural foods are more
easily digestible.
I try to stay aWay from bread as much as
possible.
Although I do.
I have started eating more sprouted
bread recently,
like a csi type bread.
I feel like my body digest that more
easily.
I think it's a little healthier.
I keep away from white flour and pastas
and things along those lines and I try
to avoid processed foods as much as
possible and sugar as much as possible.
So in that sense,
yeah,
I eat a lot of vegetables.
I eat a lot of protein,
animal protein,
fish and things along those lines,
but I just think I'm just real.
I noticed because I work out so much and
because I,
I do athletics where you sort of measure
your progress,
whether it's my workout routines like
strength and conditioning routines or
martial arts.
I kind of see what I'm on and when I'm
off and I can anecdotally or directly
correlate that between my to my diet and
I find that when I take supplements and
I make sure that I have plenty of
vitamins and plenty of green leafy
vegetables,
that's one of the most important ones I
think,
and healthy proteins.
So in that sense I,
I eat along the lines that allow those
paleo guys eat
great.
You know,
I,
when I used to be a very competitive
soccer player,
I was grossly underweight my whole life.
I mean one slash 25,
30 pounds,
four percent body fat just from running
all the time,
reading all the time,
training.
I even found some marathons.
The day that I stopped training was this
sort of pernicious and insidious weight
gain.
It wasn't sort of,
you saw me one one year,
I was 125 in the next year I was one
eight.
It was always four,
five,
eight pounds a year.
And then one day,
eIght,
nine years later,
I get on this kid and I'm tipping to 100
and the most,
I got up to fIfty two,
I'm five foot six,
2:58.
Whoa,
you're heavyweight.
Exactly.
And now I've lost about 25,
30 pounds,
but still,
even now,
I mean I'm over 200 pounds.
And one of the things that I've,
that I've been doing is,
uh,
eating,
as you said,
a lot of vegetables and a lot of
protein,
staying away from all the starchy stuff.
And I'm using my fitness pal.com.
Do you know this thing,
this calorie counting program?
It's part of this whole quantify
yourself.
So basically my,
I have to give credit to my wife.
She,
she literally counts every single
calorie that goes into my body after
basically 1400 calories in a day,
uh,
including exercise and so on.
And so as long as I hit 1400 calories
net that day and I've lost so far,
25 pounds and maybe three months.
So that's amazing.
Yeah.
Great.
Number 25 pounds in three years.
Yeah,
I mean,
now it's not totally fast too.
That's good.
Yeah.
I've now it's getting a bit rough.
I can't seem to break the next sort of
hump.
What do you do for exercise?
So I,
I'm,
I'm a cardio guy,
so maybe,
I don't know.
Maybe you'll,
you'll,
you'll guide me in better ways.
So I just do tons of cardio so it could
be I run on the treadmill or I do
stationary bike or I do elliptical.
I usually try to average between 45
minutes to an hour of cardio.
Right?
No,
no doubt about it.
And you know,
there's nothing better than having a
good gas tank and having a healthy
heart.
But I'm one of the things that burns the
most is muscle and the more muscle that
you can put on your body,
the stronger you can make yourself.
It's kind of strange,
but you get leaner.
Yeah.
Your metabolism goes up.
So yeah.
Yeah.
And I just find,
I just feel better when I'm stronger,
my body works better.
I liked the way it feels better and I
think that I can eat more.
You know,
I,
I'm a pig,
I like eating,
but I'm pretty lean for someone who eats
as much as i eat.
I have you ever seen me eat?
People freak out,
like,
especially like after comedy shows,
I'll do like two shows in a night and
I'll have two entrees and a salad and an
appetizer to the point where waitresses
think I'm joking and I'm like,
nope,
I'm serious.
I'm going to eat all that too.
Wow.
I eat a lot of food.
But um,
and I love it.
So the way I make sure that I stay lean
is I do a lot of exercise and a lot of
weightlifting.
I think that weightlifting by weight
lifting,
I'm not doing a lot of the traditional
stuff like bench pressing and most of
the stuff I do is full body exercises,
kettlebells,
things along those lines.
But when I do that,
all that intense strain that's not
available through cardio cardio,
you could do sprinting and you can
really get your heart rate up and really
get exhausted.
You certainly burn off a lot of
calories,
but that intense strain up fucking,
that's what makes bone density.
That's what makes your tendons and the
attendance stronger,
muscle density strong,
more thick,
and I think that also helps your calorie
consumption.
That's cool.
Speaking of comedians,
I just,
because very organic what's going on.
I just hired a postdoc who's claim to
fame so far until he gets into my
research program was he was studying the
evolutionary roots of humor.
Oh,
that's interesting.
And so what he basically looked at is
umer as a sexually select that trait as
a proxy for intelligence.
And so with his former doctoral
supervisor who's a well known evolution
psychologists,
they would go into comedy clubs and a
rate people's impressions of how funny
the comedian is,
and then we administer iq test to them
and it turns out that funnier people are
actually smarter people.
And so when women say,
you know,
I'd love,
they always say,
I want a guy with a sense of humor.
I want a guy who makes me laugh.
Whether effectively saying as a,
as a proxy measure is I want the guy
who's intelligence because intelligence
is a heritable trait.
Interesting.
But I bet that's wrong.
Here's why that's wrong.
I know my,
my favorite comedian of all time is my
friend joey diaz,
I think he's the funniest guy that's
ever lived and uh,
he is a very smart guy as far as like
street smarts,
wisdom and he knows a lot about life.
If you gave him a fucking iq test
though,
he might barely beat a chimp.
Right?
So I think what you're basically saying
is that iq might not be the way to
measure intelligence,
but what,
but you are admitting that he is
probably very intelligent and he's most
certainly very.
So then that's
supporting the general theory.
Oh,
it's the general theories on.
I just think that iq intelligence
doesn't matter.
your social intelligence.
He's very socially intelligent.
Like he spots like he's a predator in
some ways.
Like he spots like the weakness the
person has and is with this motherFucker
with his goofy.
He'll find out the one thing about you,
oh yeah,
that's not what you're thinking.
You know,
he'll,
he'll find the one thing that,
you know,
you're trying to pretend you're not,
but you truly are.
And it'll like illuminated like glowing
thing here.
This guy is actually a,
this is actually have that.
He's lying about this.
Most certainly know there's a study that
was done with ceos and the number one
thing that they all had in common other
than on average being taller than the
norm ceos and taller than the noise
there.
I fascinated there I think six foot two
or some.
Some of them,
I can't remember exactly the number a is
that they had very high social
intelligence.
Yeah,
it makes sense.
It makes sense,
right?
If you're an operating officer,
you're trying to keep everybody in line.
There's a lot of social intelligence
required to do that,
to manage a giant group of people and
keep everybody happy and you know,
in foster morale and yeah,
there's a lot involved in that.
Here'S an interesting one.
A number.
Earlier we were talking about,
uh,
you know,
how these hollywood types are lying to
themselves and the privacy of their
bedrooms.
How we brought that back up.
Again,
there's more to talk about that.
you're gonna like this one.
So I've often wondered whether they
believe the hype that they say.
In other words,
when somebody is posing in this way,
do you,
do they truly kind of internalized this
or not?
There's a fantastic evolutionary theory
that looks at the evolutionary roots of
self deception and other words.
Why is it that we are so good at self
deceiving ourselves?
This is by a guy named by name of robert
trevors,
phenomenological biologist,
and he proposed the theory that I think
is brilliant in its simplicity and then
what I usually do is to demonstrate the
phenomenon.
I go to a television shoW like seinfeld
to find a manifestation of that
phenomenon,
which I'll talk about In a sec.
So he says that one of the biggest
dangers that we face as humans is to
navigate all of these social threats in
our environment.
Right?
So I'm trying to manipulate you while
you're trying to read me to see my
manipulative intent.
That's called machIavellian intelligence
or social intelligence.
So one of the ways that I could fool you
without you picking up that I am fooling
you is if any visual cue in my,
in my face that would signal that I am
lying,
I would shut it off the way you,
because then you can't read that.
And the way you do that is by deceiving
yourself.
In other words,
if you understand what I'm saying,
yes,
I want to lie to you.
I want to deceive you.
I want to make you do a.
But you're going to be looking at me to
see whether there is any visual
signals that shows that I'm lying.
If I could suppress those by first lying
to myself,
then you can't pick up that online.
So then,
so there's a show on seinfeld and I
said,
how can I demonstrate this to make a
sort of more sexy in my book?
So there's a short on seinfeld where
george castanza,
who was kind of the licit,
this devious guy,
uh,
is,
is trying to teach jerry how to be a
better liar.
And one day as he's about to leave his
apartment,
he looks at him.
He Says,
remember jerry,
it's not a lie if you believe it,
and I said,
that's it.
That's exactly the evolutionary roots of
self deception.
Right?
So you the evolutionary theories
everywhere,
man.
It explains everything.
I certainly do.
I think you're correct in that.
I think there's definitely something
there,
but I can also offer some unique insight
as to the celebrity thing,
what it what it is,
because I've been a part of it and I've
also experienced it myself.
I've experienced mY own self deception
on my own ego swelling,
like in an unnatural way.
It's because of the environment that
you're constantly enter the data that
you're getting,
the data that you're getting.
If you're a star.
I've seen now I'm a nice person,
but I,
I've seen people get shows and become
these fucking ruthless dictators like
people that have sitcoms or shows that
revolved entirely around them.
I got like a,
not seinfeld,
he's supposedly a very nice guy,
but like there's this famous story of
brett butler's from that show,
grace under fire about what a useless
monster she became when she was on the
show.
Granted substance abuse was in there as
well,
which I think may also,
you know,
not just because of the fact that she'd
probably have addictive tendencies to
begin with.
A lot of comedians tend to be impulsive
and a lot of them had tend to have
addiction issues as well.
I'm sure that played into it as well,
but also the pressure of being the one
to pressure of being this one person
where when brett butler shows up on the
set,
everyone has a coffee for.
There's a script,
we get anything.
Bret,
they're all treading lightly,
you know,
they're all like worried constantly that
she's going to be upset at them.
So their data,
the data that a person like a brett
butler or some star has is that they are
special.
That's all the data they're getting.
The data,
the data that someone who has,
you know,
someone who's not attractive,
they're,
they're the only data,
like a lot of data that comes from a
person who is not physically attracted.
It'S like,
well,
I found out that I can get people to
like me if I make them laugh,
so I'm going to develop a good sense of
humor because my nose isn't getting any
smaller.
My ears aren't getting any little or I'm
not getting any taller.
I'm fucking not losing any weight,
so let me just do.
Let me just become funny.
And then you know,
you see a lot of funny guys that are my
friends that are not good looking at
all,
but have beautiful girlfriends.
Like what does that from?
Well,
they figured out the one thing that they
do have that they can find that
attractive,
that data that these actors and these
people that get,
that are famous,
they're getting
love and they're getting love from
people that don't know them.
They only know their work.
They only know this thing that they've
pretended to be in a movie where there
were a superhero or in this thing where
they were a doctor and that show where
they were.
You know,
they always had the right answer and
they were on top of things.
How many people that we've seen in
movies that we thought were like really
smart,
intelligent people?
Then you see them in an interview.
You go,
oh,
he's a fucking idiot.
He's an idiot.
He's playing a role right there.
Their data that they get is completely
unnatural.
That environment Where you,
for whatever reason,
they decide that you're going to be the
guy they put you in this thing.
They project you on a screen that's 60
feet wide.
Every time you talk,
the words that come out of your mouth
were carefully constructed by a team of
writers and they labored over those
words for weeks and weeks.
There's music playing.
I mean it's amazing exhaust,
so that environment is so completely
unnatural.
The data that they get because of that
is so unnatural.
When brad pitt shows up at a some awards
party or something like that and he goes
down the red carpet and people fucking
go bananas and scream,
he handles it remarkably well for
someone who's in that scenario because
that is a completely unnatural scenario
and must be insanely difficult to
maintain objectivity and that's in that
situation.
So that has to be taken into account.
Just the data that those people get is
so different from the data that a guy
who is working at a camera shop gets a
guy that was a normal person and normal
life that the data that they get is when
they interact with people,
people judge them based on their
appearance,
how they talk,
what their background is.
They start communicating,
they gather up data.
When you see tom cruise or brad pitt,
like you automatically like them.
You automatically have all this attached
to them and that's a totally unnatural
world to live in.
There is actually some studies that have
looked at Why is it that people love
celebrities so much and the argument is
that it's because it's tricking our
ancestral brain,
right?
You're coming into my television,
a screen every day on news radio.
I actually,
you now become part of my what's called,
want dunbar numbers on it for $1,500.
Very nice.
So you know joe rogan.
I know this guy.
I mean I remember when my kid was
blogged,
joe rogan,
joe,
joe.
I know joe rogan.
And so I think what ends up happening is
that since we obviously didn't evolve in
an environment where to televisions,
but I now feel so intimately connected
to you,
that barrier is removed.
Yeah.
It gets even weirder when you do
something like this podcast because it's
even more intimate because we're in
people's ears were an earbuds.
I'm inside your head.
I'm talking to you right now.
Maybe you're on a treadmill,
maybe you're on a plane,
maybe you're sitting on the subway by my
books.
It's books,
a member,
those subliminal things that,
those work,
those things like buy popcorn.
Remember those things.
flash in the movie,
not famous sort of popcorn and coke.
Apparently the,
the,
I don't know the exact story,
but I think apparently the company that
commissioned that study,
uh,
maybe did some massaging with.
I had a group of undergraduate students
do a similar project.
And one of my courses,
what they found is that if you put,
let's say by crush or buy a big mac,
it's not specifically the desire to buy
that product that increased.
But rather your hunger and your thirst
increased somewhat.
I mean it didn't increase your
likelihood of saying,
yes,
I'd like to buy a big mac,
but when they were asked post the
subliminal thing,
are you hungry than the subliminal cue
would affect their hunger and their
thirst but not to the specific product.
So the evidence is equivocal,
so there's a little something in there
like if you see somebody eating a piece
of cake on tv and it looks awesome,
you do that or like that.
And that's real.
Yeah,
exactly.
So that is kind of a subliminal message
or is that not to limit because it's
conscious.
It's has to be below my conscious
awareness for it to be subliminal.
Do you remember those things?
They used to sell.
I don't think they have them anymore,
but they used to be cds or audio tapes
and you would hear like the sound of the
ocean or something like that.
But then behind the smoking a message
for succession and smoking so well I
don't know if those work because I don't
think they are on the market anymore.
I know.
I think the market has spoken.
Yeah,
they were.
They were quite popular for awhile.
You hear like.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Somewhere in there apparently was like,
lose weight.
Stop eating cheetos.
Correct.
Why isn't that?
Doesn't scientology have a similar thing
with getting the clear state or
something?
I had a neighbor,
it was poor bastard.
There was a piece of property that he
wanted to buy and I found out he was a
scientologist because this conversation
he wanted to buy this piece of property
and I said,
yeah,
this is right.
It was right next to his house.
I said,
would you build on it?
And he was like,
well,
you know,
I don't,
I can't even buy it right now because my
wife was about to go clear,
like,
what does that mean?
You know,
I didn't know what it meant.
And he goes,
well,
you know,
were scientologists.
So and then so,
you know,
I tried to be as objective as possible
and that kind of sorta started asking
them like,
what does that mean?
He was telling me that she will no
longer be influenced by any outside
stimuli,
any outside influence,
any outside suggestions and that she
will be able to go through this world
without being affected by negative
anything and anybody yelling at her,
anybody insulting or they will no longer
get in there,
but it costs $50,000.
That that's,
that's the ringer.
And then remember,
I was going like,
what is this?
What happens?
And he was explaining that,
that she goes through the ceremony and
like,
that costs 50 grand.
Why does it cost us 50 grand?
So I don't know.
It's just,
uh,
you know,
it's worth it.
Fucking poor bastard.
Now why is it that so many people since
you're in that industry,
is it that it
is particularly accepted within the
hollywood crowd crowd question.
I've only met a few.
I've only met a few legit scientologists
and one thing that they radiate.
It's this weird sort of positive energy,
this alien,
artificial positive energy that's very
difficult to put your finger on.
Like,
hey,
nice to meet you man.
That's amazing.
So you deal in evolutionary psychology
as it applies to marketing.
Amazing stuff.
I'm like it a lot.
Like there's something.
It's not like a genuine enthusiasm.
It's this weird extra level that's not,
but it's almost like you want to follow.
I want to see how long you can keep this
up.
I want to follow you all day.
I want to know when the crash is coming.
You know,
I'm pretty sure that if I followed you
around,
I'm just guessing,
but based on our two hour and a half
conversation that if I followed you
around,
you're pretty much like this all the
time.
It was you,
but when you're talking to a
scientologist,
you fucking know that this is going to
end.
You can't keep this up man.
It's like if a guy's putting on a fake
english accent,
I'm talking all day like this is an
important time.
We got to know that I can't do this
forever.
No,
and this is something that they're doing
when they've got this amazing stuff.
I love it.
Love what you do in like,
like,
man,
you're going to hit the rocks brown.
you're going to crash.
Something's gonna go wrong.
But they are there centers that they
have in la,
one of the most interesting ones is they
have this anti psychiatry,
anti psychiatry center,
psychiatry kills and they have this big
billboard where the guy's got like shock
electric shock therapy,
shit on his head,
screaming in agony.
And what you don't realize when you go
to that is that it's a scientology
front.
I mean,
he'd go in there and they,
they,
you know,
they get you hooked on dianetics.
Wow.
The story of this guy is quite amazing.
He's amazing,
amazingly bad,
too.
Amazingly bad writer.
And the fact that he openly spoke about
creating your own religion,
that if you want to have real power and
real money,
you need to make your own religion.
And then made his own religion and the
books are fucking atrocious.
His movie,
battlefield earth.
Have you ever seen the john travolta
movie?
No.
Oh my god.
We were talking about it last week.
My friend elizA slessinger and I were
laughing about it.
It's a insanely bad movie with john
travolta,
who's in more of a monster giant alien
guy and it's him.
And um,
what's the fucking dudes name with the
lazy eye?
The black guy,
a forest whitaker,
forest forest whitaker's in it too.
I don't think he's the scientologists,
but he's,
he's an alien the in this movie because
you'd be amazed at how many
scientologists there are high level
people and you start like looking like
weird ones.
Like back the singer back is this
juliette lewis is like,
as you go down the list of people that
are actual scientologists is.
It's pretty extensive.
I think what it provides them is a
scaffolding for,
I think hollywood and the idea of being
and most notably actors,
because acting itself is one of the most
unstable professions.
You have to be chosen.
Could you.
I mean,
what you do is based entirely on the
merits of your work.
What you do is based on entirely on your
education,
your qualifications,
the,
your,
and the data that you've provided and
the writing that you've done based on
that data.
It's all really rock solid stuff.
So I'll right in front of you,
despite the fact that the ideologues
attack you and the fucking politically
correct knuckleheads will go after you.
What you're doing is,
you know,
it's all based on the merits of your
work.
What an actor is doing is trying so
desperately to get other people to
accept them and choose them.
And it's very weird.
It's fleeting.
It's not just fleeting,
it's so.
It's so weird that they don't have their
own.
It's very rare that you talk to actors
and they have their own opinions,
right?
It's like what they have is this sort of
conglomeration of opinions that they've
sort of subscribe to because they
believe that this is going to ingratiate
them with the overlords of hollywood.
Right?
So everyone has got damn politically
correct.
Everyone's driving a fucking prius,
everyone's voting democrat.
You know,
everyone is wearing pink ribbons when
it's the appropriate time because it's
breast cancer awareness.
Hashtag bring our girls home.
Hashtag yes.
All Women.
You better fucking have that shit.
You better have a good quote about it.
Hashtag hashtag go fuck yourself.
So they all,
they all get up.
They become a part of this sort of
really unstable and to be,
to be fame fair to someone who wants to
be an actor in the first place,
oftentimes you're incredibly unstable at
first,
uh,
the original you before you get to
hollywood,
like,
why do you want to be an actor?
Because you want to be super special,
not just regular special.
You want to be,
you want to be the guy.
I actually wanted to ask you about this
because my theory is that very few
actors want to be actors because of the
love of the craft.
I Mean,
yes,
there's opera opportunity and robert
deniro who really do this because,
you know,
they're just,
they're real artists,
but most people are really looking for
the extrinsic brooks.
Right.
It's really cool for me to walk around
and people throwing themselves off
balconies when I,
when I make an appearance,
right?
Yeah.
To make tons of money.
So would,
would you agree that that's true?
I mean,
is that it's a sickness.
It's,
you know,
the,
there's a lot of people they see like a
guy like uh,
go back to brad pitt for instance,
they see the love that brad pitt gets.
They want to be like him and what's the
best way to be like him to do what he
does.
And so what does he do?
He acts.
How hard is that?
It's just Pretending I'm going to get an
acting,
you know,
they just want,
they have a hole in their soul.
They need to fill up with other people's
attention and almost all of them that
are like really extremely successful had
some fucking wacky childhood.
For me personally,
I had a very bad childhood.
It was not good,
you know,
and because of that bad child,
it wasn't the worst.
I have friends that have way worse
childhoods,
but it was enough to create a deficit
that I had this burning desire to fill
in,
to show that I wasn't a loser.
Right.
You know,
there wasn't,
there wasn't this,
this child who is ignored and treated
like shit that I wasn't that,
that I'll show you,
you know,
and that I'll show you is what sort of
getting fame by becoming or being graded
athletics.
I mean that's what initially led me to
fighting.
That's what initially led me to comedy.
It wasn't as much I'll get fame is I'll
show you like I'm going to get great at
something.
And then somewhere along the line I
started acting.
It was.
But that was completely by accident.
They,
I never,
yeah,
never taken any acting classes or
anything like that.
I just got a development deal because of
standup comedy and I took a handful of
private one-on-one acting classes with a
crazy person.
Oh,
This crazy lady who was constantly
trying to get me to.
If I did get a show to cast her as my
mother working her way in.
Oh,
so gross.
She conversations that I had with this
lady was so brutal and it sort of like,
it was one of the first interactions
that I had ever had with someone who has
deep,
deep in the acting world and the
business and I got to be around some of
these people that were also taking her
classes.
I'm like,
you people are fucking grills.
There's something gross about the just
the disingenuous behavior.
Yeah,
but I,
again,
as we said,
I think it all boils down to like what
is that world?
So are many of your personal friends in
the industry or are they more in
fighting or.
Most of them are comedians.
I'm mostly.
My good friends are stand up comics
because standup comics is like.
And the other ones are martial artists.
Those,
those two worlds are there as solid as
he can get.
Like if you're not funny,
no one laughs.
If you don't know how to fight,
you're going to get your ass kicked,
if you.
You know what I mean?
Even if you don't know,
if you don't know jujitsu,
someone's going to strangle you.
If you,
you know,
these were all rock solid world.
There's no no getting around them where
things get weird and airy.
Fairy is when you're pretending to be a
superhero,
you know,
or you're pretending to be a.
Just think it's a.
It's an unnatural position to be in and
for human beings as you were saying,
we have this evolutionary trait where we
look at successful behavior.
We want to emulate it.
Well,
if you find the guy who's the head of
the tribe,
who's got the scars and the wisdom,
that's the guy that you want to pay
attention to because you can learn from
other people's mistakes and he shows
wisdom.
You can emulate his behavior and you can
become successful.
Well,
when someone is on tv and slash or in a
movie theater in their heads for 60 feet
tall and they're.
Everything they're saying is perfect,
you want to be them.
You know,
you want to follow them.
you want to worship them because they
seem to be exhibiting this evolutionary
thing.
And also think that the media itself,
whether it's music or whether it's
movies and television,
there,
there's an inescapable quality to being
on film that is unavoidable and some
very strange way and that your body's
not designed to absorb.
Your body is not designed to absorb
movies.
Your body's absorbed,
designed to absorb the wisdom of the
natural world.
Like the wisdom of,
you know,
that guy got bitten by a is to have the
tall grass.
You know,
it's real fucking simple.
like,
oh,
he went in the river and he drowned or
don't go in the river.
You know,
all these lessons we learned from the
natural world.
All these things that we see that exist
in the material world that's in front of
us.
But when this world is all of a sudden
been changed and now you're looking at
dragons and you're looking at the
spaceships and fucking lightning bolts
and all these things that are taking
place on a screen that aren't real,
the whole thing gets very squirrely in
our minds.
We don't know what to do with it.
So do you ever get blow backs?
As we were talking about blowback about
being,
you get blowback from people in the
industry for speaking so critically of
the hollywood types.
They're scared,
especially actors,
terrified to have an opinion on
anything.
They opinion on someone shitting on
actors because the problem is then it
would be exposed.
People would start examining,
well,
let's examine your behalf.
Let's examine what actors really what's
examined.
Some of the things you said know they
probably get mad.
Fuck him,
but I'm not going to say it.
You know,
you won't get access on this show.
I've had actors on the show.
There's not all actors.
It's like saying.
I mean all of a lot of comedians are
fucked up,
but it's not all comedians.
A lot of fighters are fucked up,
but not all of them.
I mean there's a lot of actors that are
really nice and I've done some,
like I've done movies with people like
rosario dawson who's beautiful and
famous.
She's about as nice and normal as you're
ever going to be around.
She's so cool.
Like when you're around her,
you would never believe in a million
years that she's famous.
She seems completely unaffected by
whatever mechanism.
I don't know how she got to fake modest.
She's totally normal,
which I wish I had a video of her
playing with my daughter when my
daughter was two.
It was hilarious.
She was grabbing her and like stuffing
her whole hand or mouth.
My daughter would scream laughing and
she kept doing it again.
It was so funny.
She's really funny.
My daughter was crying at the monster
outside of the werewolf.
Sorry man.
I should've worn you.
I didn't know you got to bring kids some
motherfucker.
I know there's a lot of nice people that
are actors,
like there's a lot of nice people.
I'm sure they do all sorts of things.
I know a lot of dudes that are in
special forces that are nice as hell.
Right.
And they've killed folks.
You know?
It'S like there's a lot of nice people.
I got a last year when we came to
California.
We come here every year to vacation.
I don't know if you knew it was the
wrong time.
Why don't you come to winteR?
You live in montreal?
We.
I was at uc irvine for a couple years
and then headed back to montreal and
I've been trying to get back to
California that winter is a motherfucker
up there.
What?
You had been to montreal.
Oh yeah,
many times.
Yeah.
Well shaw sent piano I guess.
Yeah,
well I grew up in boston and I used to
do comedy at the montreal comedy
festival every year.
Oh,
there you go.
Yeah.
Which is happening soon.
I guess every summer I used to go.
I started going up there and I think 92,
so.
Oh cool.
So you were saying about the special
forces.
So we,
you know,
we always hang out at one of the
beaches.
We meet people,
we chat,
you know,
we were very friendly and so met a guy
who's,
he's become now a very good friend,
a fbi special agent whose job it is to
tailgate all of these muslim extremists
around uc irvine area won't tailgate
them.
Well,
yeah.
I'm not going to be upset that I said,
well I have no worries.
Uh,
so yeah.
So,
uh,
so he's,
he's,
he's told me some unbelievable stories
of,
and he,
he too,
I mean,
he was an fbi agent who has been under a
lot of pressure to do the politically
correct thing,
right as you probably know that you're
not supposed to say islamic extremists
or islam or this or that.
And so when he hears me in some of my
discourse,
he finds it quite liberating because
here's a guy who was sort of whose job
it is to protect us from some of these
dangers who faces some of the
politically correct shackles that we've
been talking about.
We're all To our mutual friend sam
harris.
Yes.
Has had an incredible amount of blow
back in his honest and objective
assessment of muslim extreme extremists
credible.
The muslim extremists that he's
documented that he is put on his blog.
Like he had this thing where he was
saying like,
um,
there's,
there's a,
there's a video of this guy who's
speaking.
Um,
I forget what country he's in,
but he's speaking in english to this
group of islamic people.
And he's talking about the differences
between what people think of them as
radical islam and what is just islam.
Right?
And he starts talking about,
he goes,
how many of you believe in the works of
the koran,
in the word of the koran,
and in how many of you follow it?
And they all raised their hand.
How many of you believe that the word of
god is the best way to deal with
homosexuals and that whatever the koran
says,
whether they it says they should be
stoned to death,
that this is the word of god and this is
the.
And they don't raise their hand.
And like he goes into this thing about
how many of you think that women should
be silent and then they should.
You should listen to their man because
this is what god has said.
And they all raised their hand and he's
like,
see,
this is,
this is not radical islam.
This is just islam.
So all these people that say,
oh,
is so radical,
the radical islam.
And like he doesn't even realize that
he's demonstrating radical islam.
Exactly.
He's demonstrating sam harris got so
much fucking hate just for putting this
video up.
I saw all these people.
Oh,
I see what you're doing.
Shielding your,
his islamophobic with one person and
it's your islamophobia.
Yeah.
What's astonishing is that you know,
he,
he is a true liberal.
Yes.
And yet he is painted to be some hate
monger.
Well,
he also gets painted that way because
it's perceived that he supports war
because he wants to,
to suppress this aspect of,
of humanity.
And why is it?
Well,
it's because it's not over here yet.
If it was over here,
it was invading and you were getting
suicide bombs on a daily basis,
you would have a real issue with it too.
I'll tell you a great story.
Uh,
those lines.
A woman approached me who was used to be
a friend.
Now she no longer is a friend.
You'll know by the end of the story why
she said,
you know,
you know a lot about this issue.
God,
you grew up in the region.
Uh,
what is the position on islam regarding
jews?
Okay.
Well,
I mean we escaped Lebanon because we
were going to be executed.
Okay,
bye.
It wasn't by the amish.
Okay.
Uh,
so I said,
you know what,
rather than kind of go into a whole
treaties,
here's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to share with you a montage of
a moms from around the world.
So this is not the culture specific.
There's the indonesian and malaysian,
Kuwait,
the yemeni.
So these are at their sermons.
This is at the mosque where they are
preaching what should be done to the
jews.
And one of the particular,
uh,
iSlam's was showing images of the nazis
bulldozing a skeleton's into the ditches
and he was lamenting to god,
why?
God,
why didn't you give us the pleasure of
exterminating those jewish routes?
Why do you hate us so much?
Jewish rats have some version of that.
Right?
So maybe it was even by that standard
was diabolical.
So I share with her the link and I make,
I made absolutely no interpretation is
right.
I wasn't saying it's good,
it's bad.
I just shared the link.
Now she's a jewish woman whose
grandparents I can't remember on which
side had had suffered in the holocaust.
She her response back to me,
well,
in you sharing this video,
you're exhibiting the same extremism so
so when your moral compass is so broken
that the guy who shares a video in
response to a question that you asked me
is no different than the people who are
generating the content in the video.
We're doomed.
We need a better term for political
correctness
because that's even more extreme than
political correctness.
This denial of reality based on your own
ideology and that's what it is.
It's just this crazy sickness that in
people who consider themselves
intelligent,
intellectual,
progressive,
open minded,
these are the people that exhibit this
ridiculous train
because I think they just have this
instinct that to criticize an other is
gauche is wrong,
especially when that other is their
religious views,
but
is that true because they have no
problem criticizing the heck public and
senator who believes in creationism and
wants to teach it in school.
They're fucking hate to the end of time
about that fool.
That's true,
but if it's some in mom who thinks that,
you know,
women should cover themselves up like
they look like jabba the hut or what was
the boba fett,
whichever one,
whatever it is,
please direct your hate mail to joe
rogan.
Come coming,
bringing on benches.
It's silliness.
It's my silliness is not.
I almost have more disdain for the
people that are progressive that have an
issue with someone criticizing this.
Then I do the people that were
brainwashed and ingrained with religion
because these,
the people that are supposedly
intellectuals are supposedly responsible
for guiding the thought of the young
people,
the people that are supposed to be the
folks that are the ones that are the
curators of these ideas,
the ones that are the ones who are
teaching children in school.
There's these are the wise ones who are
professionally intelligent.
You're supposed to be professionally
objective professionally wise and you
have this ridiculous notion because of
the environment that we live in,
where this politically correct,
whatever you wanna call it,
ideology has has gotten so infected.
It's such a bizarre computer virus of
the mind blow the king of these,
these guys.
Yeah.
Although it has nothing to do with islam
as a noam chomsky.
I don't know if you know much about.
Sure.
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
I jokingly play a game called the six
degrees of separation of noam chomsky.
So I give you a calamity and in six
causal links,
you have to link it back to why the us
is evil.
So,
you know,
an,
a,
an amazonian frog died in six causal
links or less.
You have to tell me why it is the fault
of the us military industrial complex as
to why that frog that because he used
the whole world through very,
very,
uh,
you know,
a myopic lens,
right?
A hamas is nice.
Uh,
Israel is a evil apartheid,
racist state,
and you think this is a jewish guy who
was spewing this from his,
uh,
safety of his confines in mit office.
Now I grew up in that world.
I promise you they're not going to take
too kindly to you,
uh,
when the lights are off.
And so it's just,
it really is amazing to kind of
understand,
understand the schizophrenia position or
for example,
queers for palestine is another one,
right?
Palestine.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a huge movement.
I need a t shirt.
Queers for palestine t show.
It's fine if they have a cafe press.
Which area in the middle east can you be
opened and assume your sexual
orientation?
It's an Israel.
Yes.
Yet what's going to happen to you in
some of those other areas is not going
to be very pretty,
and yet these people are able to
completely disassociate from that
reality.
It's like uncle tom's.
Right,
right.
It's kind of along those lines,
I suppose
a way that.
Yeah,
the,
the idea that for whatever reason,
this one religion is the one that you're
not supposed to criticize.
I don't understand how that happened.
I wonder if it's connected in some way
to the suppression of the people that
live in these places.
Where are natural resources is being
stolen by the war machine,
which is undeniable,
undeniable.
What's going on in Iraq or Afghanistan?
How much of it,
how much of the hustle has to do with
the natural resources,
whether they be the poppy fields,
whether it be the minerals in
Afghanistan,
whether it's the oil in Iraq,
the undeniable that these people are
being sure for sure they're are subject
to the war machine that's coming in to
steal the resources.
Right,
and that,
that that's,
that's something that people are aware
of and you see these images of these
people and these islamic countries that
are dying,
they're getting bombed on and and also
the dea humanism that they're subjected
to by a lot of people that are trying to
justify this,
these wars,
that,
that is the only thing that makes sense
to me.
And also the fact that this has happened
over the course of since 2001.
This is when this anti islamophobia
notion has been really,
really pushed harder and harder.
Well,
I think it's also because that's the way
that I demonstrate how tolerant and
progressive I am by showing that I am
not going to lump everybody with those
crazy nine slash 11 people.
And so again,
it's part of that progressive posing a
no ideology,
no belief system is free from mockery
from criticism.
And the quicker we find that out and the
quicker we fixed this problem,
the better we'll be off.
Do you think that that's possible?
I mean this is the internet in this is.
This is where it gets really weird.
His internet is supposedly where the
ideas come out.
You know what I mean?
This is the,
the age of information.
This is where it's all on the table.
So you're saying is it,
is it is going to be possible to
suppress criticisms of islam for much
longer?
Yeah.
Is it going to be possible to keep up
this ridiculous facade?
Well,
I think,
I think one of the ways that you
suppress it is by creating an ethos of
self censorship.
So,
so if I open up my laptop and I can
write on my psychology today,
blog,
the 3 million people,
I have a real clear choice to make that
day.
Am I going to write something that can
bring heat to my young children?
And then I have to decide whether I'm
willing to do that or not.
Now the fact that I've already engaged
in that calculus in that calculation
suggests that we are the canaries
singing in the coal mine.
And so I think we have to be in an
environment where we don't engage in
this type of self censorship.
So,
so I think we're definitely down the
wrong road.
I think many academics,
uh,
privately will speak about these issues
very openly with me,
but we'll never even so far as go as to
like something on facebook less they
will be.
I found out so crazy.
You got to worry about your standing.
You gotta worry about your public
standing gotta worry about your Job.
You gotta work.
That's more people to be self
sufficient.
You know,
less to tHink about in that regard.
But when you're an educator,
how can you be?
in one sense,
you have tenure.
That kind of helps a lot.
But tenure creates a lot of hubris.
There's a lot of guys who have tenure
that also become untouchable and they
force feed their students their ideas.
Apologies.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And actually I wrote an article on my
psychology today blog,
what I was talking about,
the necessity for tenure,
but also its potential for misuse,
right?
Because you do get an incredible amount
of deadwood with tenure.
Right.
Do you foresee a time where universities
won't be the main source of education
that was somehow or another to be taken
care of online?
That's a good question.
I mean,
right now there's a development of.
Have you heard of moocs are.
No.
Moocs are.
I know joey diaz calls moocs or fucking
move over here.
Oh,
he had dumb.
Okay.
The ball.
Hey,
right here.
A mooka know a moocs are a massive
online.
I can't remember the rest of the day.
These are courses that are often times
offered under the auspices of a
university,
but they're free courses where people
can massively registered.
You have a teaching a course,
100,000
people.
Mit does that.
Mit does that as a whole lot.
Actually.
I tried to to hook up with these guys
called coursera that organizes a portal
for this,
but they don't have a contract with
concordia and it has to be between a
university and the organization for it
to fly.
Uh,
so I do see a potential eventually for
sort of a more democratization of
knowledge,
but I don't suspect that we're going to
lose the university anytime soon.
This is the social aspect of it.
That's so interesting.
You know,
people go away and the party and they
have fun.
They find themselves in Canada though.
Yeah,
it's interesting.
[inaudible] I've studied both in the us
and in Canada.
A yes part of my study.
And so this greek system going away to
college,
not being close to your parents,
uh,
the drinking games,
that's very much,
much more so of an american right of
passage then it is a canadian.
Most canadian students end up going to
the school that is physically closest to
them.
That's interesting.
Is that because it's so paid for by the
government.
So you've got.
You got it.
So in Canada you don't have
historically.
I mean now some programs are getting a
bit more privatized,
but historically everything is big
brother,
so there isn't this huge hierarchy of
universities,
the harvard and then whatever and all
schools are public and so yes,
mcgill university is more famous than
some other kenyan university,
but on average all canadian schools are
quite good and you have about 40
universities and so there's really no
point in choosing between them and going
across the country.
In the us you have 3000 colleges and
universities.
There's wildly varying on everything in
terms of price,
in terms of quality.
And so I think that's what makes it a
bit more exciting to choose and pick.
But then Canada,
they're all good.
That's interesting.
And in the United States they also have
universities that cater specifically to
religious ideas too.
Like the,
what was the one that,
that,
uh,
someone got in trouble for during one of
the elections for taking support from
and that they wouldn't allow interracial
couples.
Remember that?
Brigham young.
Was it bringing me up?
It might've been bringing me on.
I don't,
I don't remember which one it was,
but if some southern university,
and I forget who they were supporting,
but it became a big problem with them
that they had had become aligned with
this university that didn't,
didn't allow interracial couples like,
whoa,
like,
you know,
at what time the,
the real problem with that.
Obviously it's racist,
but also the varying scales of race.
Like is it only pure blood,
you know,
what are you a fucking vampire?
Like,
like what if someone is like one slash
16th native american is that,
you know,
is he interracial dating a blonde woman
from Norway.
You know,
what if the woman is like one eighth,
chinese,
one corridor,
like when do we draw the line and she's
half chinese.
Like what the fuck?
What if she lies about it and said she's
eskimo.
To think that if only I converted the
seventh day adventist,
I could be living in southern
California.
Man,
dude,
you could've been rocking it and teach
bullshit and teach them bullshit in line
about jesus.
It would have been awesome.
Maybe I still might accept them hand.
Yeah,
you've been tanning.
You can tend to montreal to for about
three weeks.
Montreal,
you probably know this joke.
We have four seasons,
winter,
winter and july.
It's true.
Well,
july is pretty awesome though and
everybody's very festive.
One of the things that I love about any
place like Canada or a lot of parts of
Canada is that they really appreciate
the summertime because of the fact that
water so brutal.
We oVercame it.
That's exactly right.
It's the festival sort of city of the
world because we're completely cocooned
from say end of november till say mid
april and so we make up for it.
I think it also develops character too.
I've talked about los angeles and that a
lot of people that are born and raised
in los angeles,
so like spoiled rich kids that you know
also won the lottery.
TheY don't realize how easy they've got
it.
Like the worst the weather gets here,
you have to hit a button and turn the
aca is the most brutal thing you have to
do is use your finger to press a button.
Well,
I remember when we lived here,
when I was at uc irvine one time we were
driving on the highway and there was a
warning weather advisory because there
was going to be 10 minutes of rain and
when it rains the the roads dependently
become a bit more slippery because of
the oil stat.
I don't know exactly what it was.
I.
So I'm thinking,
you know,
we drive in minus 30 degrees in small
stars.
TheY have warning advisories when it
rains for 10 minutes through.
You guys have character.
We have none.
We're done.
I'll give up my character to move to
southern California.
Well,
you've lived a bunch of years up there.
You realize that the winners are not
worth it.
They get,
they are brutal.
They,
especially if you have to go anywhere.
If you could work out of your house all
winter long and you had a good supply of
wood and water and food ready for you
and a bear once in a while to shoot.
There you go.
Then you can stay warm and full.
But California,
there's pros and cons.
The con is obviously that everybody
knows about it.
And so you've been here,
you've been here since 94.
Oh,
okay.
So you've been here for 20 years.
Yeah,
it's a.
But I grew up in boston and also
delivered newspapers,
so I drove every day,
300,
65 days a year.
So snowstorms,
everything.
One thing is good.
I know how to drive in snow.
I know to drive real good.
Right?
Like when the asset and my car kicks
out,
I don't sweat it at all.
Countersteer,
it's like instinctive,
but you know,
it's more pleasurable to live here if
you don't have the.
I mean,
could you break out into the bostonian
accent if you want it to?
Yeah,
I kinda,
you know what?
I fought once in the bay state games,
which was this big olympic festivals
when taekwondo was going into the
olympics and I won it.
So I got interviewed on television.
I heard myself on tv.
I was like,
oh my god,
I sound like a fucking idiot.
It was,
my accent was so strong.
Yeah.
We've been working,
had training for this.
I'm like,
oh,
I didn't realize.
I didn't realize how gross it sounded.
So I abandoned bandler heart too.
I just abandoned it.
I mean it comes out every now and then
if I have a couple drinks in me here,
a little bit of it.
Right.
But it's a weird accent because I've a
little bit of new Jersey to New Jersey.
um,
man,
we're just about out of time.
Is there anything else you wanted to
talk aBout before?
I just wanted to thank you.
I can't believe all the three hours.
three hours was like three minutes.
I know you're best ever.
Ah,
that's ridiculous.
You're the best guest ever.
It was pretty easy to do.
Look,
we could do this 100 times,
man.
Let me know when you're back in town
again.
We'll do this again for sure.
On your books,
what could people buy?
Where can they buy it?
What do you suggest?
So I'll probably,
if they want the sort of trade book,
the book that's written for the masses,
the consuming instinct to millions,
what?
Juicy burgers for robberies,
pornography,
and gift giving reveal about human
nature so that they could get on amazon
and they'll be listing of my other books
there.
They can check out my psychology today,
blog,
homo,
consumer focus,
where I write about everything.
Religion,
politics.
When you say you better say something
else real quick,
homo sapiens kind of homo consumerist
gotta.
Be real careful.
So.
Okay,
well listen,
thank you very much.
Is a really fun conversation.
I really,
really appreciate you coming down here
and spreading some knowledge and
information is really fun to talk to you
too.
We really appreciate it.
Likewise,
you could follow gad on twitter.
It's a gad saad.
I say it right,
the sad g a d s a,
a d on twitter and the links there also
to his website and you can find these
books on amazon.
Do you have any on books on tape?
Is it on there?
Not do that.
You need to audio tape your books,
man.
Read your books and with that sexy radio
voice.
That's what I'm talking about.
A dog do it.
You got it?
You got it.
Flaunt it.
All right folks,
so we got another podcast coming up in a
little bit tonight,
uh,
with uh,
david seaman.
He'll be here in about 10 minutes.
So until then,
much love my friends.
Much love.
Please support our sponsors.
A blue apron.
Go to blue apron.com.
Forward slash rogen.
That's blue.
Is that it?
Why am I having a hard time finding it
here?
Where's the copy of?
There's two copies here.
Okay.
Blue apron.com.
Forward slash rogen.
That was correct.
And you will get two free meals.
Delicious.
Healthy,
nutritious,
low in calories.
I just started using it and I really
enjoy it.
I love the fact that I don't have to go
to the supermarket when I'm busy.
It's all delivered to your house.
Give it a shot.
And like I said,
you'll get two free meals,
blue apron.com
forward slash rogen were also brought to
you by [inaudible].
Go to [inaudible] dot [inaudible] dot
com for $25 off of any of their
delicious cellular devices.
All right,
we'll see you soon.
Bye.